two
what's up what's up what's up what's up
let's go everybody let's go it is monday
june 13th we are
live
reporting from los angeles california
uh
here with the gang
good afternoon everybody
ab nice hair slick going on there no
thank you thank you is that a new look i
just did my hair real quick in the
bathroom so it's still you did some gel
a little bit a little bit
nice monday baby
some gel some nice hair for monday yeah
sorry not beautiful oh
jordan's not a fan tough audience no
now jordan is not a fan of the hair i
think it looks good don't listen
not beautiful all right
dan olivia sam in
zachary
sweet young zach the whole gang is here
we're all here let's see the rolex put
it up
oh baby whoa you had to do it
so is every profile picture going to be
like this now you know something like
this yeah yeah
yeah absolutely
uh a quick thank you to our wonderful
sponsor hellofresh this summer make all
your meals easy and breezy with
hellofresh you get fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and recipes delivered to
your door every week get 16 free meals
plus three gifts with code
h3tv16
at hellofresh.com
h3tv16 we love hello fresh thank you
guys we love you so much
okay
what a day are you guys following the i
mean the whole economic world is
collapsing
let's go
i don't know if you guys have followed
it's pretty interesting
i mean a horrible i mean i've lost so
much money in the stock market now yo
you're in trouble that crypto [ __ ]
that's true that was
tell crypto however has taken the
biggest beating
love do you still have crypto you do
right
why are you gonna ask me that bro
i'm hurting i'm hurting yeah
are you holding though you're not
selling right oh at this point i'm two
years old
so yeah i gotta hold
i might buy some more
i mean now's the time i guess it's a
fire sale yeah it sure
is um
well that's fine can you just give me an
idea how much of your portfolio have you
lost by percentage
[Music]
60
oh no
damn it
from the peak that's from the peak
though
i'm still up because i invested very
very early are you still up there
that's good i'm up
still up like 50
so
oh wow dude you're like warren buffett
of crypto hell yeah baby but here look
at this sorry love look away if you need
to rod and pop um
it's been so crazy let's see one month
look at that six months this is bitcoin
six month chart man
let's see it was at 50 000 that wasn't
even the peak was it
i guess back here was at
i guess it was the peak 50.
i guess now he's just having a big joke
out of it
and i'm sorry the peak is probably
further back actually yeah just flip it
to the five year that gives you a better
impression well i know
okay so here the peak was at like wow
sixty thousand
you know
and now it's a perspective of how crazy
this rum was though you see the little
peak on the far left yeah that was the
2017 one where everyone was like
freaking out like oh my god it's going
crazy or whatever and look it's like
dwarfed by what happened in the last few
years well you know i'm i actually this
is actually really sad because i know a
lot of good people are losing money
right now because of people like gary
vee and logan paul and jake paul and the
all the there's all this other
billionaire who's jake paul says it's
spiden's fault oh god can you pull that
tweet up that was just like a tweet of
the century
um
and there's this other billionaire who's
always shilling crypto too he's this
indian billionaire what's his name
he's a young guy slick looking
uh i think i know you're talking about i
don't
remember yeah
anyway like y'all you all really got
played by gary vee
like i hope you guys know that actually
this isn't the one that we were talking
about but here's an even better one
jake paul moore my generation left or
right agree with me we need the
president of our country to do
he didn't have the time to spell out
better i oh man don't know
okay well
show me the the crypto one i sent it
yeah this there here it is look at get a
load of jake paul the political analyst
biden's accomplishments highest gas
prices worst inflation plummeting
plummeted crypto prices
joe biden is destroying crypto
like of all the things to blame him for
at least high gas prices and worst
inflation you could like
maybe
you at least there's like some
correlation because he's president but
crypto what the [ __ ] has he remembered
he's taken crypto he's tanked the crypto
markets by refusing to implement any
regulations he's done nothing he
literally has
and then also everything else here is
obviously
uh
i mean completely not biden's fault and
that's just kind of the cycle of things
that always happen but
this isn't the political podcast that's
on thursday so this one might be his
fault
created new incomprehensible language he
may
jake may have a point with that one uh
i shouldn't i shouldn't say that i
should
put
okay well well i celebrate that
personally yeah i think that's one
that's correct
yeah guess what
what cozy economy oh not not now hurts
nobody people are hurting biden don't
benefits everybody
he's lost it man he's so off base
but yeah i mean
i don't know man the only people that
really made money from this whole crypto
bull run were people like garyvee who
probably made a billion dollars
and now
all of his you know well
providing a valuable service with uh the
v friends
like yeah
can you really put a price on art
well some say would know some would say
no you can't so
supposedly gary vee made 90 million in
90 days
yeah of course he did you know and like
just remember and i'm very sorry to the
people that lost are losing a [ __ ] load
of money right now just remember all
these people who told you that crypto
was gonna
make you rich and solve all your
financial problems and all this [ __ ] and
just remember how much money they made
and they used you because i don't think
we should let these people
get away with it right i mean gary vee
should go to [ __ ] jail probably for
what he did i mean i'm not i'm not a
i'm not a [ __ ] uh
law enforcement but the way that man
fleeced his audience is is
staggering um
but he will not
just remember guys because there's he's
going to stay around and he's going to
go on to the next craze look at ethereum
this one even hit harder and this is the
one that gary's um
household thing is run on right all the
nft stuff well not all but most of the
nft stuff is on ethereum yeah yeah so
the ethereum actually got hit even
harder than bit
coin and this this is like a total
collapse happening here it was up at
like five thousand
and now it's down to
1250 dude that's crazy how's dink doink
doing
how's it going
doing think dog's up no i don't
is that 100 trillionth of a cent
[Applause]
is my favorite corner once you dunk on
my face and take a dink on my door like
yeah so cute and cool i love this crypto
project
it's so dumb
ah shout out yeah those two guys man
those paul brothers sure know how to run
a scheme
tell you what they're gonna be president
logan paul be president logan paul will
definitely be president in the next he's
going to change the u.s currency to
ethereum
he's going to do he's going to do 365
days of presidency
exclusive nft drop
the craziest photo he can take as
president the first hundred days my
first hundred days president yeah it's
going to be the best and polaroids yeah
it's going to change the world much so
broken though
but you know the stock market is also
down it's just a whole total implosion
right now
not looking good i mean this is what i'm
invested in the s p 500
i guess it's not it's not as bad as the
crypto markets but it's pretty bad
i mean high was at
40
40 800 which was insane but good news i
read an article this morning that
despite all of the signs of a recession
upon us and everything
the housing market shows no sign of that
there's no i believe continue to live in
an apartment for the foreseeable future
thanks
i hate to say it but this is like the
worst economic
situation i think you could ever face as
a society you have crazy inflation
last month they reported like nine
percent inflation year over year which
is insane sick the highest since like
1980
okay so you have massive inflation
and then also the housing market is
insane
and also there's a recession coming
so
by oh my only advice is buy guns boy
forget crypto but guns are the currency
of the future
dr disrespect says he's the two time but
i'm the three time living through three
count them three recessions in my
lifetime
baby the american economy continues to
chug along yes
the good news is to everyone who took
out who has hundreds of thousands of
student debt
massive inflation means technically
uls money oh interesting that is
assuming your wage increases which is
not
right oh yeah
so the american experience is thriving
everybody welcome to the future
that uh works for everybody
this is dedicated to everyone who lost a
shitload of money this week and just in
the past few months
i just want you to remember that the
american dream is alive
don't give
you know why
[Music]
that's america
that's america to me
sing it come on guys
let's go
breezy just donated ten dollars and said
dan the housing market is going to crash
i work for a title company i deal with
house sales every day interest rates are
going to about sell oh yeah then here i
forgot to mention interest rates are
insane and only going to get higher
let's go
that'll be the one bright spot
not for
people like you that own a house ethan
but for me who don't
when the housing market correct yeah but
then but then like how are you even
going to get a mortgage if it's like ten
percent
right
that's like it's a double-edged sword
i'm glad we got our house in michigan
when we did the value went up sixty oh
really two years what are you guys doing
with that house you're renting we run it
to my little brother yeah oh [ __ ] good
for you guys
damn so it's so expensive people even
move into michigan
yeah exactly
damn it's tough out here y'all
yeah i was shocked by the prices here
for homes it's ridiculous
well and since i bought like my first
home that my you know i bought my first
home
like five years ago so 2017 or something
and it's gone up like 50
i mean it's sick it's actually just sick
geez
it's not it doesn't make sense it's
unsustainable and i think obviously our
society is crumbling
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
you said society so
no
society brilliant timing i love jared
leto man that guy never misses with his
performances doesn't he
[Laughter]
well we have a really fun show here
planned today um at two o'clock we're
having martin the water sommelier come
in
and i'm tugging the water yes and i've
been following martin on tick tock and
he's such an interesting guy
um at first i was like this is so stupid
you know your gut reaction is like water
smelly this is so dumb but the more i
follow and you know i'm a skeptical guy
the more i followed him the more i got
into it i was like this guy actually
is making sense to me he's a water guard
and this is a water bender like he
doesn't buy into any of the bs with like
ph levels he goes ph level doesn't make
any sense it goes in your stomach
the acid destroys it
watch this i'll just set you guys up so
you guys know what we're getting into
but here's martin
doing a tour of cvs waters and giving
recommendations
hello hello everybody here's martin you
personal waters for me i'm in front of a
cvs farmers and the whole vibe is
immaculate
okay we have
three different refrigerators so let's
check it out
let's open this
so we're starting with ice kenji and
natural spring water
good water oh then
sorry i did the review already in
florida a little problematic before
they're like so many different
uh ones out there they're coming from
five different sources so you really
don't know which one you're getting
but it's at least a spring sauce
aquafina
from pepsi
the same from cola processed tap don't
buy that
okay again what i consider a good water
here we go
idiot great water
then we have
pure water already the name says it pure
huh so it's highly processed tap water
don't buy that
[Music]
earlier when we were talking about the
ph i felt like i was
like about to go into a science test
like you're with all your friends trying
to go over all of the info right before
you go and sit down oh yeah we're like
yeah no because the ph levels they like
hit your stomach and obviously like that
doesn't matter that makes sense because
like the there's been this whole gimmick
of like ph level 2000 like it's a
[ __ ] dbz superpower
and uh he's right our stomach is made
acid what the hell does the water
acidity matter you know
um
yeah so he he knows every water this
guy's breath of knowledge is insane he
knows every water and the way he rates
like if a water is good he considers
like the source if it's a natural spring
or something and then also there's a
thing where he measures like the amount
of minerals in it and apparently the
it's good for you right having those
natural minerals and
water but here's the he's going to bring
in all kinds of water for us to do a
taste test
i'm excited man we're getting wet today
baby we are getting wet you got to know
how do you become a water sommelier and
i saw a tick tock that man was flying
business class let's go and i'm like yo
yeah
the water business is good
so that's something to look forward to
thank you
peace
obviously a lot of stuff to talk about
um but first i want to say thank you
a shout out you know our our new
collection came out on
friday teddyfish.com if you have any
money left
[Laughter]
and you need clothing
consider
teddyfresh.com it's all popping
so many nice pieces here
this jacket is fire obviously
you know look at that come on now
um this shirt's been doing really i love
this shirt it's beautiful
very jacquarded
super nice
love the image this is ela cline
original hoodie
it's called smile more and there's a
matching pants too really beautiful
piece love how that came out
um
floral skirt floral shirt
this women's t-shirt is so nice
i wish you guys could see it but it's
super nice and it's got a freaking car
zipper i mean how dope does it get
doesn't get cooler than that folks
what am i wearing oh yeah this just came
out
a little color blocking t-shirt really
nice
it's all happening
oh yeah here it is
anyway
if you need clothing and you have money
consider
teddyfish.com
thank you
and if you don't have money buy some
ramen or something don't
don't spend it here
start stocking up on on dry goods
because we gonna need it
get that toilet paper
if i'm broke i ain't using toilet paper
i'm using whatever i find you know what
i mean toilet paper is expensive we've
been through this den
the paper is a luxury i'm sorry
i just
showed my whole ass here literally did
anyway my brother got married over the
weekend oh yeah congratulations
i don't want to say anything leaving up
to it because
people are weird and they'd like to find
out where and stuff
but um i dressed up as
it was a star wars themed wedding okay
and i went all out it was hot man it was
hot day
and i went all this chewbacca suit i put
on i went all out i bought this like
life like chewbacca outfit
music oh yeah and it was so hot dude
i've never been i think i was almost
having heat stroke i started feeling
nauseous
and i can't see that's why i'm walking
like that there's just two tiny little
slits so i'm like
but we we pinned the yarmulke on the
head
you're chewbacca walking like yoda
chewbacca walking like yeah chewbacca
there
i mean
it was awesome it looked amazing right
but boy people were worried about me
because we started taking photos later
and i was like and literally
there was i could feel just drips drips
coming down my back it was nuts
but you know
i kind of blacked out the whole wedding
to be honest i don't even remember
anything i swear to god i barely
remember it so were you the ring bearer
or were you just walking down the aisle
for the ceremony i was walking down the
aisle okay
i also and then
my theodore was the ring bearer and it
came in a little death star
and so he came down after me and he's
like here you go daddy i was like oh
cool thanks i didn't know what it was
and so i just put it i gave it to you
stole the ring i didn't know what it was
i missed the rehearsal
nobody told me [ __ ]
so i gave the death star to like my
brother-in-law because i didn't have
pockets
i almost threw it in the bush i was like
i can't hold this right now
i'm in a chewbacca outfit i'm so up so
they're doing the ceremony and then my
brother goes do you have the ring oh man
the rings please and everybody's looking
at me i was like
what i didn't know she would bring i
don't have [ __ ] you just point at
theodore it's his fault and then they're
like the death star and i was like oh
[ __ ]
so inside the death star they had two
star wars
rings these guys are dedicated yeah and
so
even after everything huh even after
the new movies and
the rebellion never dies there medicated
man they're dedicated okay chewbacca
lives forever
badass but um yeah i seriously blacked
out i
i don't remember the wedding i'm not
even kidding
and i also learned i think i so you guys
remember how i have like taken a new
medicine will butrin mm-hmm
and so
lately
i was talking about how i was sweating
like a beast at post malone's
listening so
just all the time i'm sweating like
crazy from nothing like
my face is blotchy and red and i'm just
my head is like so
and i find out that a side effect of
wellbutrin is excessive sweating one of
five people
so i'm like oh so here we go
not only i'm fat now i'm a sweaty mess
thank walburgin
i haven't lost any weight but now i
sweat a lot
well the water weight yeah that's about
to say water weight i don't know is that
a myth i don't think sweating actually
helps you lose weight does it it does i
think yeah it does yeah well i mean
temperature water weight not real weight
yes correct i mean unless you're doing
obviously cardio which makes you sweat
but that's
a different source but like not really
you need cardio i don't know if you guys
know this but you need water to live
right there are these um
like sauna houses that people go to
where they like wrap you in a tin suit
and i think it's supposed to promote
weight loss but it just gets rid of all
your water weight at the
yeah i remember martin
lawrence or something he almost killed
himself you remember that in like the
90s he was jogging in like 100 degree
weather in a sweat suit trying to lose
weight
sweating itself doesn't burn calories
but sweating out enough liquid will
cause you to lose water weight yeah
just dehydrates you it's not a good
thing
there you have it a glimpse into my life
you know thank you
thank you everybody
little uplifting news here at the top of
the show
um
our boy
wally p
a-okay
the gofundme we hit up for our boy here
he had a goal of five thousand i want
you guys to know we smashed that
twelve thousand
hundred dollars
for our boy wally p okay wally p is
gonna be okay
steve jablonski of course always
chipping in legend
i'm trying to get a shout out too won't
let me either
anna comment shout out uh presley aranda
shout out avery avery you're such a
generous king avery or one of our mods
shout out
thomas ribeiro shout out and you know
god bless everyone dance word love
that's right i had to support my boy
whoa generous king
although avery donated 11 more than me
so he showed you feel obligated to
donate twelve dollars to outdo him yeah
well you gotta have to redonate though
to top the chart because it's separate
all right sorry getting 212. i'm the 100
anonymous muslim in there you're what
you're are you on here too i'm playing
there's a hundred dollars anonymous oh
yeah you can take credit for that yeah
because he doesn't want any muslims
donating so i don't know as much oh [ __ ]
right right right right he canceled the
whole gofundme if he found any
islamic yeah and there it wasn't me
no but we love him he's been through a
lot are we working on tracing his um
life story yet is that something we've
started yeah well i started i read up
some more uh after we talked about it
last week i i don't i don't have a
powerpoint presentation uh prepared or
anything yeah i just need a timeline you
know sure just like a chart okay because
i want to get i want my ideas to get
wally back on the phone
his life is incredible and tragic and
fascinating
uh i want to chart out all of his life
and then confirm with him if that's true
okay because obviously
communicating is uh
not a hundred percent
shout out to uh
our
surprisingly uh
large contingent of
both kurdish fans and iraqi fans uh on
the episode um on the thread on the
subreddit about it there was a very
interesting and nuanced conversation
going on about everything that happened
to wally and the history of the kurds in
iraq and everything and um
i was uh
delighted to see you want to write it
huh you you want to read it
it was really long i mean they were very
long in-depth comments between like
three or four of our fans that were on
there and uh i was just um
i
i mean i guess we have fans all over the
world but i'm still a little surprised
to see that we had so many fans from
that region yeah lots of real
interesting uh
conversation and it was nice to see
another more uplifting news tony our boy
who's battling brain cancer who we all
wish and love
uh as we raised 20 000 so that's really
cool wow
has keemstar donated yet let's see
john scarce read i forgot about that oh
it's steve jabalonski jablonski is such
a candidate i know i know
he really is
dallas crollow i don't know who that is
but shout out
john scarce i love that dude flexing on
keemstar is the best
and
thank you to everybody who donated to
help out tony
poor tony man he's in the hospital
getting like
extreme intense treatment for his
brain tumors essentially
and he's still just
having to think about keemstar it's like
damn bro
so sad um
where's that where'd that tweet go it's
in the dock
we have an album so if i send it in
discord it only sends one image at a
time
i hate that yeah
where is it
it should be top of the dock i'm
highlighting it right now
so frustrating it's not
just put it in the sec
where is it maybe
it's right here where i don't see
anything very top it's highlighted
yellow oh bright yellow that's not the
top
that's like the middle oh it's near the
it's top-ish
it's literally right
look look at all this stuff over it
okay it's uh about
so tony says you know
six inches down in the dark right
we don't need to yeah i mean it's more
than six it's like above i mean here's
my screen
here's my screen right well i guess we
have to account for different
resolutions let me try if you guys
really want to keep these calculations
standby i mean top is top right
wait i'm i'm crunching the numbers right
now
yeah you're right on uh i mean get a
ruler we can measure it i mean that's a
good 12 inches from the top of the
document i mean if we want to have this
fight i couldn't find it either because
i was looking at the top thank you
olivia
see i'm not don't i'm not it's not
because i'm a [ __ ] and we all know
olivia's smart
super junior olivia is still in her
not on your
it matters what's on my screen bro
give me the ruler
here we got a tape measure
all right well honestly like and this is
i mean that's well that's like eight
inches yeah eight inches total
so
we go yeah but i mean the dock really
starts here well he could have put it
anywhere you could have put it up there
these are just sponsors though i want to
put them up there well i was expecting
him to be right here right at top of the
ship which you already talked about this
listen
but relative to like what we were
talking about it's just right no that's
not top of the dock i didn't get to any
of this stuff yet it's still on the top
of the show so
the screen real estate is about five you
didn't say top of the show you said top
of the dog
i'm saying it's eight inches down
get out of here take this and get out of
here
go away
dumb dumb no it's not i just measured it
i just measured it i just measured it
too the screen starts here you can't
this is cheating this is cheating
okay so so what's this what's that this
is five and a half inches yeah and then
approximately
one more
six inches down six and a half yeah
i know how long six and a half is i've
measured many times
that's that's pretty long
i've heard
i'm sorry i thought i saw olivia record
we were talking about that
i mean it was hilarious
um
i always think about that anytime a guy
is like oh it's about six inches or
something i was like oh really
i happen to know what six inches is
exactly i can measure it every time
it's incredible
any other measurement of distance i have
no idea but if you tell me in six inch
length i [ __ ] i can nail it every
time
it's amazing [ __ ] um
all right thank you a.b anyway
tony
yeah over the weekend had to hand his
phone off to his nephew because he was
getting constant calls
from keemstar fans calling him a pedo
tony akeem ended up going back and forth
about it over the weekend can you
believe this
this man is literally dying of cancer
and keemstar is still [ __ ] with him i
mean this man
this man has no soul i mean let's not
forget what he said to totalbiscuit when
he got his cancer diagnosis you have it
zach
can't wait to report your death
he literally told a man who had
diagnosed with cancer who tragically
lost the battle he was a friend of the
show and a great guy
uh i can't wait to report on your death
i mean guys come on this is this is
inhuman [ __ ]
i mean it is but what keemstar said is
gonna put all my pride aside for the
constant [ __ ] over the years and
from you and wish you well so it's like
it's not really a well wish it's like
let me start off by insulting you
and then say i'm gonna be the bigger man
after insulting you it's like you know
it would piss
why can't you just say i wish you well
you know that would have been nice but
he can't do that he can't he literally
is incapable
tony responded he said even in death it
seems i cannot escape your never-ending
lies and [ __ ] please just let it go
once and for all i mean it's true right
because he brought it up he he basically
called him out gonna put aside all the
constant [ __ ] over the years it's
like dude shut the [ __ ] up man he also
said from you
like he didn't let it lie as [ __ ]
let's not forget how this started okay
you went on your show and accused tony
an innocent man minding his own business
of being a p word
and he's still getting accusations of
that today now here his nephew tweeted
out a few days ago we had to take away
tony's phone because of your fans
calling and saying he's a pedo
then they started calling on the
hospital phone keemstar the worst part
is you still say it's everyone's fault
but yours
pretty nuts right
oh so i haven't seen keemstar's
responses
none of my fans called you a pedo you're
literally lying um
are you aware of who your fans are
whoever's left watching your show would
absolutely do that
like always for years you've been
trolled online like all of us and every
time you get trolled you blame me
because you know you're gonna get a
retweet from h3 diabetes
is that my new nickname h3h3 diabetes
this is the only way to you get
attention
dude he's not here's the thing about
tony he's not like a slick internet user
like us he didn't choose to be put in
the spotlight the only reason that guy
was putting the spotlight is because you
falsely accuse him of being a pedo so
yeah people are definitely going to do
that and you can't blame him for his
inability to process it like in a way
that we would because this is do he you
know what i'm saying
random people hitler well that's true
actually
what did he say to him keemstar my uncle
doesn't even know where he is right now
half the time but i'm sure of one thing
the people that are calling him know
yours
and use it every call keemstar is still
in denial it's disgusting man just say
you're sorry and stop [ __ ] bothering
him it's nuts
did anyone watch this the lost recording
series
no i didn't watch it
uh someone's gotta watch this yeah i'll
watch it take a look
story about your fans harassing tony
while he's fighting cancer that's going
to be a lot of views for your dying
channel someone said to keemstar my fans
are not harassing them it's simply not
true how do you know that
keep start keeping tabs on every single
one of his fans why don't you ask them
for proof for the claim they made dude
they're saying they got
calls at the hospital
why would they lie about that
and also
how are you supposed to prove that
someone said prove that somebody called
you a pedo and prove that they are my
fans
i mean i see people saying that to him
even on twitter and his replies
uh why can't you admit your horrible
hateful downright malicious false claims
directed because this man continues to
receive uh to this day because it's not
true prove to me the [ __ ] evidence
what are what are people calling him a
pedo where are the screenshots where are
the receipts prove the claim
prove it
oh god this is like a i forgot he even
did this catfish story
holy [ __ ] that's like crazy here's the
fake catfish story you pushed after all
the backlash you got for the first pig
fedo story
oh i can't believe he's taught doing all
this i had no idea
i could believe it remember what he did
when basher died
yeah he said you have i sent the tweet
but basically
uh you have to wait at least a week
before you talk [ __ ] about some of the
past and then the dramaalert instagram
which he claimed to not run posted the
picture of um his breakdown exactly and
then he said i'm not going to remove
that and you can wait a week and find
out why
that's [ __ ] up
i love that he goes we all have our
penis but when they pass we must respect
them
while tap
literally tap dancing on his grave uh
wait at least a week this yeah this is
bro you are [ __ ] in the head dude he
hasn't the crazy thing about him is he
actually has a track record of literally
attacking people when they're dying
or like pushing people when they're
actually dying which is obviously to a
length that no one would ever go to in
fact i wouldn't even expect keemstar to
go to that length yet he does every time
it's incredible it must be yet like some
sort of power
trip
i don't know yeah yeah because it's it's
a pa it's like a consistent pattern it
is i mean
it's been
etika
basher now tony total biscuit that's
four times well that's when they're most
vulnerable i mean if you look at it that
way yeah for sure so it's like but like
yeah no you're absolutely right but like
who would go that low you know he also
like it came out that tony had cancer
and then keem decided to start something
with him
it's unbelievable he knew that that
comment was gonna piss him off yeah
that's why he wrote it exactly
yeah and then by the way when people
were angry at keemstar for
publishing a fake pedo story about tony
then he's put me he's like no no no
here's the real story he got catfished
by one of his mods like some weird
fringe [ __ ] conspiracy
just trying to humiliate him i mean it
was so [ __ ] crazy
it had nothing to do with the catfish
story he was catfished by someone and he
was getting trolled by that group and
then he was blaming the trolling on me i
wonder why they were doing it
do any of you and then they sent you the
story and you published it [ __ ]
interesting
do any of you people even know what the
hell took place
uh keemstar the only person oblivious
enough to believe that not a single
person from a fan base as large
as his would be attacked
for a man who is falsely accused of
being a pet on the past
what you said is not proof show proof
okay whatever this is a lot
it's actually been raging on twitter
about this
my fans are not doing it he goes yo i
don't have fans so how can my fans do
something if they don't exist
that would be a fair argument actually
yeah that would be his best yeah
his best one he could make it himself
he should have said something like look
at my engagement
it's clearly not me yeah he's like bro
look at my come on
find me one fan find me one fan and then
we can
and then we can and
interrogate them
yeah it's awful honestly i just hope i
keep telling tony because i've been
talking to him
and i say just just don't even think
about it because you know
if he is going to be passing
and it seems like he is going to be just
to be blunt
just the last thing he should be
thinking about is keemstar which is so
sad it is it's so sad that that's what
keemstar wants is for him to be thinking
about and when he dies
evil
it is
and so i said just you know don't just
put away the phone just be with your
family you know think about all the
people that love you on the gofundme
and just focus on that man
you know
what is this loss tape so i'm gonna
watch that
it's oh it's only four minutes what the
[ __ ]
so just screen it and find out if it's
if it's good
um
yeah keemstar is a monster it's true
i i it's just incredible to me that
people are like associate with him
you know it's like dude you're actually
friends with this guy
that's crazy to me
it's so crazy
what is this oh he's still bitching
about me this is from just a few days
ago
this is awesome
kim started bitching about me
from just uh three days ago yeah
awesome how did you how did you this
come up on your on your it only has 2
000 views how'd you find this this is
ian actually how'd you find this one ian
this is a good uh he retweeted it
oh yeah yeah there you go you see his
retweet resulted in 2 000
views
this [ __ ] is giving interviews
to 6 000 subscriber channels and getting
2 000 views after he retweets it i mean
look at this
this man has no fans how dare you guys
accuse him of
of his fans harassing dogs making a good
point actually right yeah keemstar
you're taking the wrong approach on all
this uh 10 year old fan right away
right right
if he does have fans they don't know how
to operate a phone i'll tell you that
all right here we go the third
person on his podcast on the h3h3
podcast
and uh went there met him was open had a
conversation like i'm having with you oh
you are so [ __ ] pathetic this
happened years ago
dude even when he tells the story it
doesn't sound that bad right listen uh
they were very nice they were lovely to
me we had a great conversation
um and when i left uh and got home and
was back here in buffalo new york uh the
podcast went up and
some people were mad that uh they had me
on the show because i'm a very
controversial figure
they left a comment
on their uh
on the video which was on youtube and
they said i know some of you guys hate
keemstar don't worry we hate him too and
i was like what the i was just there
yeah and i was openly hostile during the
interview right
i said the whole content the whole
comment was don't worry
i know you guys hate keemstar we also
hate him but we think he's an
interesting character and the interview
is is is good it's a good conversation
okay a little bit insensitive i
apologize to him i erased the comment
you know
and like
the man cannot let this go it's pretty
[ __ ] incredible
and this is when he started going after
me and my family and everything and just
like never letting up so it kind of
forced me to
to take all this head on
tell me you hate me face to face like
you know what i mean like i was just
there i was like
and i'm pretty sure you could find an
excerpt of me basically saying that i
hate him from that interview like
there's got to be a really close
example of of
of me saying i dislike him to his face
and so that company
started a feud but then
h3h3 he um he got sued um
and when he got sued it was shut the
[ __ ] up
show your hairline [ __ ]
anyway i didn't mean to talk about
keemstar all this i just got all fired
up seeing him [ __ ] with
tony it's crazy man
it's nuts
all right well
i didn't mean to go down that rabbit
hole but what we do have
is
um
should we do a ad is it 30 minutes
yeah i was gonna martin's gonna be here
just a few more minutes so that we could
time it with martin's arrival um why do
you guys do this to me this isn't the
first time y'all did this to me you go
my arm
stretch in impossible ways and i don't
and i've seen this image before and i
look at my arm is completely normal i
don't know why
no on camera it doesn't work no it's not
it looks crazy right like that yep but
but look at my arm it doesn't look weird
right
it looks fine yeah you're kind of over
bending it though it's kind of no i'm
not i swear to god i'm not look
i i swear to god i'm not over bending it
um i say what you mean you know it's
just some crazy optical illusion i feel
like
where am i that's what i thought at
first but then i looked on the subreddit
and i guess this has been a thing for
years yeah it's happened before
yeah last time you did it on the ethan
klein channel i posted it on twitter
look at my yeah my hands look insane
right now right they look like they're
bending the wrong way
but they're totally flat
i think that's just you though
i think in correlation to your
shoulders
it they're like they point inwards i
think that's what make it make it look
weird
looks normal to me no
come stand here i'd be let me see your
arms a lot of people saying that you're
just double jointed i'm not double
jointed what does that mean
all right just do like this put your
arms down like this next to me
okay let's see
exactly your elbows do the same thing
no go straight yeah she they do kind of
actually wait do you put this arm up put
this up
i mean it looks a little crazy right
you're right actually there's some weird
thing going on here okay so it's not
just you so am i acquitted
oh guys do you see i mean mine looks
more extreme look how [ __ ] crazy my
arms look right now
i look like a fish bro yeah but i'm
telling you my arms are straight
look how crazy it looks
i have three inch arms
but it's normal
my arms are totally normal i'm telling
you it's crazy i've been talking about
this for years dude yeah so i asked how
did you finally acknowledge it i asked
eli i'm like have you ever noticed this
about ila's arms she's like yeah and
once you notice it you can't unnotice it
wait wait wait say that you asked ila
about my arm yeah when i was looking
into this
like on camera or she said my body's
[ __ ] disfigured
no on camera she meant
my arms look crazy right now
but they're full normal hands it's crazy
look at this
little like birth defect like birth
defect i mean with peace and love right
normal
birth defect
it's crazy
uh
people are tripping out about it because
it really does look so nuts like this
so your elbows hyper extend is what i'm
seeing a lot of people say what do you
do
hyper extending elbows yeah i mean i
have it too i have it too i'm maybe it's
more obvious with me
hold on let's see this hyper extending
elbow nonsense maybe that's why you're
so good at throwing a baseball it's part
of it elbow extension
what most people can't do that that's
[ __ ]
no the other one everybody can do that
no you have a slightly overextending
wait
show my arm for my arm
so i can see it
it doesn't even go it's not even that
extended that's as much as it goes down
it's straight yeah when you hold it like
that it does look fairly straight oh my
goodness me
[Laughter]
we need to study your your whole
physiology
love has it
yeah i have overextending arms too yeah
yeah there was with that one angle when
you're head on we look like a fish you
look like peter griffin with the small
arms
everybody's spamming the t-rex emoji one
more time totally
look theodore i'm a t-rex
psych
martin's here the water guard has
arrived oh and the dogs don't even bark
at him you know he's got that water he's
got the water vibes um why don't we uh
do our ads real quick and while you're
doing that we can uh kind of prepare
with him and all right i'm gonna thank
our sponsors while martin sets up the
fountain of youth
right
is there do you have fountain of youth
water martin
right oh you're 65.
he said he's 65 obviously
what the [ __ ]
bottle that [ __ ] and give it to me
wait how old are you martin
still looking good i'll tell i'll have
what he's having
all right let me thank our sponsors real
fast
thank you so much to babble
babble babble
for most of us learning a secret
language in high school or college
wasn't exactly a high point of our
academic career
i took german man and
it's just hard learning another language
is it martin german
is it martin german
yeah we can test that you're german
right martin
i could test sure i mean it's been a
long time since i spoke german i
literally just said i wasn't very good
at it right
but now thanks to babel the language
learning app that sold more than 10
million subscribers there's an
addictively fun and easy way to learn a
new language whether you're traveling
abroad connecting in a deeper way with
family or you just want to have some
free time there
babel teaches bite-sized language
lessons that you're actually going to
use in the real world now i know ian has
been studying hard hard hard you've been
studying the french language right the
uh uh right there ian
okay seems like you haven't picked up
much since we started since you started
months ago oh miss yeah
do you want you want to you want to show
show me your the
the whole range of language you've
picked up
uh well
water in french
i'm pretty sure is oh
oh yeah
oh yeah
oh okay so there you go babel works guys
he's picked up one word
in five months
blue a stunning endorsement of babel
blue
oh
oh is that like a robot saying it yeah
it just i did i didn't get to that the
lesson part the pronunciation part no
i actually i have used babble uh just to
try it out it is really fun and
addictive it's like there's all these
really fun games i'm telling you if you
guys want to learn language this is the
way to do it babel's 15 minute lessons
make it the perfect way to learn a new
language on the go other language
learning apps use ai for their lesson
plans but babel lessons were created by
over 100 language experts their meth
their teaching methods have been
scientifically proven to be effective
and with babel you can choose from 14
different languages including
spanish french italian and german
love actually learned sw uh uh uh uh
swedish
why did you feel that's not hey hey lupo
yeah so there you go that's pretty
incredible plus babel's speech
recognition technology helps you improve
your pronunciation and accent
there are so many ways to learn with
babel in addition to lessons you can
access podcasts games videos stories and
even live classes plus it comes with a
20 that 20-day money-back guarantee so
you really have nothing to lose there
start here think about it dude right
start your new language learning journey
today with babel right now save 60 off
your subscription when you go to
babel.com h3tv
that's babel.com h3tv for up to 60 off
your subscription that's babel language
for life thank you
and finally
everybody's favorite
fresh
these meals are insane these meals are
delicious they're healthy they're
balanced
go up go up go
oh [ __ ]
what's in that burrito
that looks so that looks insanely good
the grill marks perfect you can just
tell that there's something really
awesome inside no history in that
doritos
it's not there's no there's it's history
it's not an edible ingredient
god is in that burrito
yeah but in trip what what
how many aves burritos are in that
slideshow is there more than one i just
throw it in between that's awesome so
that i can quickly access it that's
awesome i love that yeah i'm telling you
man
here's the deal about hello fresh if you
want farm fresh pre-portioned
ingredients and seasonal seasonal
recipes delivered right to your doorstep
it's time to skip the grocery store and
count on hello fresh to make home
cooking easy fun and affordable and
healthy
that's why it's america's number one
meal kit
hellofresh delivers fresh quality
produce from the farm to your door in
less than a week
and you can savor summer flavors right
from home
hello fresh newest menu release includes
mediterranean recipes that are filled
with fresh fruit veggies nuts olive oil
and fiber packed whole grains for
nourishing balance
listen i absolutely love hello fresh
if you're good at cooking or if you're a
novice at cooking it's honestly great
you can learn a lot
and the way they do it is they send all
the pre-portion they send a little card
that tells you exactly what to do and
nice little information about your food
and um
it's awesome man they say it's even
cheaper than going to the grocery store
because you don't have to buy huge uh
quantity stuff you get the perfect
amount
everybody in the super trooper nation
loves hello fresh go to hellofresh.com
h3tv16 and use the code h3 tv16
for up to 16 free meals and three free
gifts my friends that is hellofresh.com
h3 tv 16 use code hbd16
uh thank you uh hello fresh america's
number one milk it all right
so let's take a look okay we're gonna do
it here
so take a look
i'm joined by
and martin you are the only sommolier a
water sommelier in america is that right
no it's not
did it used to be right it used to be
right yeah you're absolutely right so
how many are there now um they are on
the planet around 250 and in america in
america i think three right now
currently
who are the other two do we respect them
absolutely no no i respect everybody who
has passion for water right i think
that's that's the goal here would you
say that all living animals have a
passion for water it would be nice but i
see millions of people don't care about
water on a daily basis that's the whole
point why i'm doing this right right
right
so um
okay so first of all tell me before we
get into the taste testing
how did you decide to become a water
sommelier
so i'm from obviously from germany i
think everybody can tell when i'm saying
hello everybody's like okay that guy is
sherman
i've been raised at the danish border up
north where the baltic and north he
pretty much meets
and on vacation time with my parents i
was like four or five years old
i realized that the tap board in every
single city in europe tasted differently
to me
and my parents i was like what's wrong
with our with our son he's not drinking
the bottled water we have in the car
he's like waiting literally like until
we're like stopping somewhere and the
first thing i'm doing is running to the
tap and drinking the tap interesting so
i was fascinated about that i had no
clue obviously as a child why water
could have actually different tastes
and i i have to say i forgot a little
bit of my teens i had other things to do
let's say like that i used to be a dj in
germany as well so my passion was for a
little bit more electronic music
but then in 2005 i worked in berlin in a
mission lost a restaurant and a guest
came to me and said hey martin you have
so many different wines on your wine
menu but you're just serving one brand
of water and he didn't like the taste of
that particular brand and he asked me
like what else do you have
and i looked at him and i thought like
hey
he's kind of right it's all about
options in the restaurant business but
when it comes to water we know this here
in ia as well the only question you
might be getting from the server is like
what do you want still sparking or tap
right right so i thought i got to change
that
what were you doing at the restaurant at
the time before you transitioned to
water small i'm i'm a management hotel
and restaurant management okay i see
that's my my business i wonder if you
have some kind of
mutation or taste you have a different
taste experience than us because the
experiencing that at a young age so
powerfully uh something that i would say
the vast majority of people wouldn't
even notice do you think you have some
kind of
different biology i believe that every
human person on this planet has a
special gift it doesn't matter if you're
maybe a comedian or you're doing great
podcast for example you have a gift
there that you can entertain people
so other
people can cook so they have the taste
abilities to recreate different taste
profiles based on the different
vegetables to create a new amazing dish
so that's what the chef doing some other
people can create beautiful music some
other people can create beautiful
paintings
i maybe can taste some water
hey
you're right everyone does have a gift
when we break it down like that
um
how's the water tasting business i saw i
saw a tick tock of you flying business
class i was like damn martin what's
going on here you're critiquing the
water in business class of course um
yeah i had a little fun with you and
united airlines because they were
serving me a nestle pure life and that's
not really up to my pallet standard
if you're you know
no i called them out for it because i
think like when you're when you're
flying business class obviously there's
[ __ ] a lot of money you're paying for it
absolutely so
why you think it's okay to get then the
wall like the the cheapest water ever
created on this planet that's for me
just like this
it's some some misconnect to me right
like when you're paying for luxury i
expect luxury when you're driving a
porsche for example you expect that the
engine will hold and you can go on a
track with that thing i think the
problem like
when i first saw you on my tick tock
feed which is how i found you
i was like this is insane like this this
i thought it was like a joke but the
more i watched you i understood that you
actually
knew what you were talking about and i
was actually ended up being fascinated
by it i think the problem is that
people don't have the same taste
experience as you with water like most
people would fly that and be like well
whatever i don't care it's nestle or
whatever
so i guess i guess probably one of your
challenges is to
make this water experience more
mainstream yeah i think it has several
things to do first of all
my german accent is like okay here's a
european accent this can for some people
they love that some people say like oh
my god he's already pretentious because
he has a german accent
then the word sommelier obviously has
not the best meaning sometimes by just
normal people who are saying like you
know what it all tastes the same to me
i've been certified as a water sommelier
when i said in the beginning like i'm a
water expert they thought i'm working
for the department of water right right
so that didn't fly so i thought like you
know what i'm gonna stick with the water
somebody get title because that's just
like it it kind of like makes sense what
i'm doing yeah but the the last thing i
am and i think this is like the big
surprise what you had as well ethan in
the beginning you would think like a
water so may come on this is like the
most potential thing ever this is
ridiculous water is water this is
completely nothing crazy yes but when
you're like listening to my tick tocks
for me it's more like i want to bring
attention back to water because let's
face it 780 million people don't have
access to that like they don't even have
running tap water
so it's a privilege what we're doing
here today yeah we have bottled water in
front of us so we might as well goddamn
enjoy it yeah and then it's a privilege
as well to have running tap and i'm not
against tap water at all i think it's
extremely important to have good and
safe clean drinking tap water and we all
know that even this country
we can 100 guarantee this because we
know what happened in flint michigan
absolutely i have plant michigan tap
they give you this in a documentary
it smelled like two lemons were like
squeezed into your nose
that was like the smell of it obviously
i couldn't drink it it's poison oh right
you smelled it it smelled it they gave
me a sample it was disgusting it's
called what lies upstream the
documentary and it's yeah it's unfree
it's a it's crazy to think that even in
america
which is apparently the land of planet
there's people who don't have safe
drinking water there how do you make
money
i'm still working in the restaurant
business obviously okay okay but i'm
helping water companies okay so i'm i'm
i'm generating obviously money as well
through for helping water companies and
not just water companies you can solve
for them i'm consulting for them or even
a motor car like a car company just
approached me and said hey martin we are
releasing our new car in palm springs
people need to get hydrated afterwards
so why not talking about the benefits of
different waters to the media people
when they're driving a car interesting
so it doesn't need to be just water or i
just helped a very famous vodka company
in the states to reformulate their vodka
based on the different minerals infusing
because water has a huge impact on all
other beverages wow so my that's pretty
cool that you're becoming like a water
consultant yeah in general
it doesn't need to be just water there
you know guys you can pursue any passion
and you can make it happen the man loves
water martin
and
ethan i love what you just said because
i think this is so important for in
general everybody it doesn't matter what
you want to do but do it with passion
right don't see it as a job do it with
passion put all your energy in there
be obviously on that niche all the time
having the same red line in your vision
and you will make it do you have um
extra taste with anything else or is it
specifically water do you taste
everything robustly it's very
interesting obviously do like since 2005
i'm like i'm always saying drinking
water professionally now that i'm like
really like really thinking about water
so extremely
and my palette changed it's kind of like
going to the gym well the first day at
the gym you're like oh my god i cannot i
cannot press that sure but
three or six months later you are easy
to do this the same with your taste
panel you can train it you can train and
train and train and i have actually my
own academy it's called the fine water
academy i'm certifying water swimming is
around the world online you you can
certify that now yes i'm sort of fine so
i wanted to ask you how do you get your
water sommelier credentials you were
credentialed
in europe correct in germany and germany
so this is a real school yep for water
so what's that like yeah it was
interesting a lot of blind tastings a
lot of a lot of going to the restroom
because that's the most important thing
when you're a water taster you always
need to know where the restrooms are so
we're not spitting it out like wine um
there is a documentary on natural
graphic that followed me to china and
you will see me spitting out the waters
and a lot of people say like now this is
like the craziest thing ever yeah like
why is he spitting out water you kind of
get drunk but when you have to taste 120
different ways i know it's so funny
though to see you spitting it out but
you need you're right you're right
you're because first of all you need to
go to the restroom and second of all
your brain at one point will say i don't
want to drink water anymore yeah yeah
and when you have to judge waters it's
not fair for the waters you have later
on in the in the flights and you have to
like like this and you need to go you
don't want to taste them anymore so who
who has the best water in the world
would you say best tap water where have
you had the best tap water best tap
water switzerland uh scandinavian like
for me it's coming out love we have a we
have a swedish here how's your tap water
there love
it's insanely good
you guys don't buy bottled water or any
of that [ __ ] right you just drink from
the towel no never yeah yeah
it's night and day i used to drink you
know up in northern california i went to
school in santa cruz and we all drink
the tap water there but in l.a tastes
like [ __ ] it has something to do like
the more northern you get in this
country the more rain and more snow you
obviously have so they have more access
to water
versus here in california especially in
los angeles our water comes maybe from
the colorado river so we all know that
has to be pumped over here so they want
to make sure it's safe to drink so
they're adding so much chlorine to it
that literally like nothing like
you know i don't know
people in la may have noticed when you
put i put like tap water sometimes when
i don't want to go downstairs in a cup
or a bottle and in the morning it just
reeks of chlorine it's really
interesting yeah but they need to make
it safe and in yeshua and i totally
understand the government there that
they want to do it but for me my advice
is like even like on your skin and your
hair this chlorine is just crazy so
therefore my advice is just buy yourself
a like very super cheap i have like for
60 bucks i think a shower filter on my
shower head well you don't even shower
in town no no no it's a it's a filter
but it's like 60 bucks it's not
expensive you filter the water that
comes out here and i filter what the tap
water does and then it's like literally
after two days night and day to your
skin into your hair right away
that's [ __ ] interesting um martin
might be on to some [ __ ] here noted for
sure no do it you're right because
there's chlorine in that [ __ ] i've been
talking about since i got back from
school my hair has been so brittle and
my skin has been so oh my god it's the
water
no why is nobody ever mentioned that
that's actually blowing my mind
yo where can i buy that i went to
america my hair was super dry and that's
actually what i want to do that is
exactly what i want to do
you just [ __ ] blew my mind
who wants to drink super expensive
waters i don't care that's the thing
that's at first i thought that but i was
like this guy's the real deal what's the
name of that filter
smell that [ __ ] and i have no
affiliations with them no it's just like
it's not that people think like oh that
guy has like a contract with him nope
what's the name akfarzano ah akbar and
then zana s-a-n-a
all right and unexpensive great stuff
and they have everything from
systems over
me neither okay can you spell that for
me because i need this [ __ ] uh aqua like
the the what is this the latin word for
water oh
yeah sorry about my german accent again
r q u a correct and then zanna s-a-n
accusana
oh like this
aqua zone if you pronounce it like no no
no no s-a-n-a
[Laughter]
i thought you speak a little german come
on ethan here we go
oh yeah baby guys
all right look at this even even sirius
are already recognizing it
guys check it out
i don't know i'm gonna i'm definitely
gonna try this if you're captivated with
me right now we're already getting crazy
water tips from martin aqua sauna
i'm sending this to elo i'm saying buy
this [ __ ] right now
and that we are all on the same page
because this question will for sure come
up there is no best water
let's stop this whole nonsense of theirs
best because everybody asked me this and
every water company thinks they are the
best and obviously when you have a lot
of passion for when you own a water
company i totally get it but there is no
best water because we are all humans
we're all having different needs we all
have different tastes but there's good
waters in bad water in my opinion
absolutely yeah no there's there's in my
opinion real water and fake water
that's what i think
i'm just writing this aqua sauna down
there i don't forget so let me ask this
first of all let's say you don't have a
lot of money because some of this water
is like very expensive so if you're on a
budget what's the best way to get a good
quality water filter tap water
totally fine absolutely
done
it will do exactly the same job than the
super expensive three or four dollar
high ph waters it's all marketing and
the ph stuff what's your opinion on the
all that ph stuff in my opinion it's the
biggest game on planet earth that's my
opinion
even compared to bernie madoff
whole thing is completely nonsense
because let's face it and you mentioned
it earlier because i was listening into
the podcast earlier yeah yeah and you
said like the whole ph thing even the
inc the american institute for cancer
research wants for the alkaline diet
they even saying and you talked about
cancer and my mother survived breast
cancer i'm very lucky that she survived
and i love my mother so i'm very happy
that she's still with us
but i know that some people trying to
go to the people of especially cancer
treatment facilities and saying like
yeah you need to buy this water this is
the best water because you will fight
your acidic level in your body what is
all so brutal nonsense so why is it
[ __ ] yeah like what's what's
happening when we're drinking water it
goes into your stomach your stomach is
super acidic 1.5 to 3.5 liter every high
ph water will get neutralized right away
right right it needs to be acidic
because we have to break down nutrition
and what a lot of people don't know
actually what the second very important
reason is why your acidic needs to be
super like your body needs to be super
acidic on your stomach you need to kill
bacterias because when we're touching
our glass or we're touching a bottle
we're touching our hands we're putting
this into your mouth there bacteria is
right there we're breathing in bacterias
even so everything goes through your
stomach it will be killed right away
that the ph thing is [ __ ] because
the marketing on the ph thing has been
insane let's face it it's everywhere
i've remembered a trainer when i was
doing i was doing personal training i
know it doesn't look like it but a few
months ago happy to help
really sure i'm here for you water diet
it's not water diet but like i'm trying
to stay fit and yeah water
water can help you actually a lot so he
he was saying though he's like make sure
to get this water with high ph
you know i was like okay sure why not
but that's
this is a crazy thing look i'm from
germany again europe so we don't care
about ph whatsoever nobody even would
think about ph nobody cares about that
everybody cares about something else and
it's called tds
and this is
total the soft solid and that's the real
thing that's how you judge water yeah
it's not just that i'm judging the water
this is like where water in general base
is judged by so tds it stands for total
dissolved solids and when it comes to
bottled water that means how many
minerals are dissolved when it comes to
the epa who controls the tap water
quality
they're actually warning for high tds
waters over 500 because there might be
something else in there but the fda who
controls bottled water does not want for
it so i can explain to you very easily
why so the epa department of water and
power puts the water into the pipes
around most of the times between 100 and
200 tds so they know exactly is that the
natural tds are they adding no they're
obviously they're adding fluoride
they're in the chlorine that makes up
the tds as well so tds can be great and
can be bad so yeah it's so on face value
it it needs further analysis to know
correct so there they know but they know
exactly at the department of water power
when they're putting it into the pipe
they know exactly the tds and what is
made up so from that standpoint it's
safe
but when certainly your tds at home is
500 or 600 tds and you're probably not
something good something happened yeah
so there may be a spillage somewhere so
you need to test that out that's the
reason the epa tells you please check
your tds level sometimes on your tap
when it's high you should maybe call the
department of water and power and they
need to do some investigations but we
want to make sure that everybody's safe
yeah by bottled water obviously they
know exactly what the tds is when
they're filling it into the bottles so
the tds is mostly made up of the mineral
content
it's safe it's regulated by the fda and
the minerals as vitamins and natural
stuff that your body needs not vitamins
but electrolytes for example magnesium
calcium sodium potassium comes from
rocks and stuff correct yeah we all
learned this hopefully in in high school
or maybe in elementary school the water
cycle so the water evaporates from the
ocean it goes
creates clouds goes to the main island
hopefully it's gonna rain here at one
point los angeles again because we are
facing a very big drought right now and
this is actually not fun guys please
save water everybody and call out water
and call out actually companies who are
wasting water that's way more important
than then your your little water intake
what you have on a daily basis doesn't
mean anything but like the agriculture
people they're like the big water takers
here
in california yeah so
by this being said
um
so
look at the tds and you want the high
tds because electrolytes and minerals
are great and this is something what you
actually want to have i see i see
very interesting stuff um
someone's asking are brita filter
filters good do you approve totally fine
with me okay but the only thing with
britta they're actually german-based
company i always loved them but suddenly
i saw them that they are selling now
purified tap water and aluminium bottles
on the store for like three dollars and
that was nonsense i want to ask you
plastic versus glass i know a lot of
water comes in plastic bottles is that a
problem that's the sad part i would love
to see more glass bottles for two
reasons first of all it's great workout
i know glass is heavy but hey let's face
it you can you can do some workout
already to carry glass bottles back and
forth from the store
uh plastic is just not the best
container i totally get it for
convenience reason and even with some
hotels forbidding you to bring glass
bottles i totally get it though
therefore we have now aluminium as well
but i think it's way better than glass
but the best container is still glass
you think uh aluminum is better than
plastic yes
do you do you think people say the
plastic bleeds into the water can cause
cancer all that [ __ ] is that um yeah
their studies been done but this is just
happening when actually the plastic
bottles are getting exposed in a lot of
heat okay i see so it's not when a
plastic bottle is in a room temperature
room or something it's just a flavor
thing it's a flavor thing but obviously
i know as well like what's in a glass
versus was in a plastic bottle it's two
different products in my opinion right
right so i try to stick always with
glass so when you say there's fake water
and real water what's fake water so real
water is for me water from comes from
natural curing sources so again water
cycle water comes down as rain water
goes down the different soil stone
layers and take them in reality with
them red canes are built on that pretty
much okay pretty cool that water the
universe is solvent has so much power to
dissolve stuff incredible it's amazing
actually what water does
versus fake water is for me when a
bottled water company sells to highly
processed tap water so they're using
municipal sourced water from montebello
or wherever this there their facility
sits they're opening the tap processing
it that means they're filling everything
out oh good stuff they take all the
chlorine all the whatever out but all
the electrolytes are small minerals yeah
and then they're adding back very small
amount of electrolytes then they're
adding and they're saying on the label
electrolytes added for taste but
everybody thinks for the consumer
oh this is so cool they're adding
electrolytes my doctor told me i need
electrolytes so i should go to buy that
these waters has barely any electrolytes
added why don't they add more
taste reasons because they they're
trying to create a charming boy they
don't want to go too nuts on the taste
because then people will say i don't
like the taste okay i see so they want
to keep it it's kind of like cooking a
soup when you're adding too much salt it
will be very salty your soup and then
you won't like it so the natural
occurring ones have a higher electrolyte
count but they still taste good is that
what's going on it all depends on the
balance and that is the cool thing it's
kind of like when you think magnesium
for example is green and potassium is
yellow and you have maybe sodium a green
color when you mix them all together
as an artist you can create a beautiful
picture this is what pretty much nature
does and we're going to discover this
today because these brands what i
brought taste differently you can
actually taste
the origin where they're coming from
that is a cool thing right and that is
for me
in my lifestyle i like to eat when i'm
for example eating a carrot i want the
carrot coming from the farmer's market
and not pre-bagged in a small plastic
bag sure who barely has any taste
anymore okay the same for me with water
i want that my water comes from natural
cooking do you do you spend a lot of
money on water for your personal
yeah i think like i think it's all about
what you want to do with your money and
some people spending money on beer some
people spending money on liquor how much
money you spend on water a month
it really depends the cool thing
obviously for me as a water summary uh
because a lot of people know me these
days around the world that's why a lot
of water companies send me samples so
i'm getting at least three or four
different brands you have a nice water
oh i have like 50 different brands at
home okay that's cool so your need to
spend
has diminished
correct yeah and that's the reason i
don't want a good quality water does not
need to be expensive right that's very
important to me so did i ask you this
what's the best let's say the best
value water that's like the best quality
for the best price that someone can go
into cvs or a gas station and find this
water what's the best look you saw my
videos already and you showcased earlier
the cvs video where i'm going in florida
to the cvs and saying like yes yes no no
yes yes
so it's not about the branding and i
know it's something so we're used to in
america that's all about branding well
you could there's not one you can point
to like this is the good one i would not
do this because
when when i say brand a like is a great
tasting water that does not mean that
you will like the taste right but it's a
quality water so it's about the source
for me yeah so that is way more
interesting so look at the labels and
when it says source
mineral water spring water or whatever
like ice water glacier water that means
they're actually coming from nature and
the one sort the sources to avoid and
then purified water vapor distilled or
distilled water is for me something what
i would never ever drink and i think
again that's but again that's my humble
opinion as a water source yeah of course
it's my opinion it's for me the biggest
game on planet earth to to sell the
consumer
a marketing story highly processed
glorified tap water what they actually
can do itself it's pretty incredible
they sell back the tap water to people
like a thousand doesn't exist in europe
it doesn't exist that whole business
model is not exist that's so interesting
but it exists in america somehow the
consumer was triggered by celebrities
who are smiling in the camera with some
bottles and
oh so wait there's there's some really
popular brands i want to ask you about
smart water that one is super popular
it's expensive everyone loves it good
brand
i i
what should i say the word already says
everything for me in my opinion smart
water is a marketing gimmick what is
smart about that water has a tds of 38
is super low in electrolytes and
minerals and it's people love smart
water
wait wait it says it says it's boiled up
tap water that's what vapor
is the marketing word for what's boiled
up is this just the company that makes
it cause it almost looks like glacier
it's coca-cola oh oh it's cocoa cola
it's coca-cola guys wow so they really
got us good with the smart ones oh they
did an incredible job on the market and
it's just an apparent terrible shot but
it's it's nothing else than highly
processed tap
so what's what how did they get us with
the smart water thing is it just like
that they've got alkaline in it or so or
the
levels anderson was the big thing for
them they had a contract i don't know
how many years yeah it says vapor
distilled water and electrolytes for
taste like you said the typical [ __ ]
yeah and they they don't even this is
the problem here there's no regulations
in america when they're saying
electrolytes added for taste how many
electrolytes they can add right so when
they're adding just one tds what means
like barely anything they can still call
it electrolytes interesting interesting
it's from it's again
like so wait guys tell me other waters
okay essentia that's another one that's
like super expensive that is super hip
essential water
tell us this is the whole idea about the
ph was essential so oh yeah this one is
this one is super popular what is even
over hydrating or every overachieving
mean it says it says overachieving h2o
they called it once uh
um locally sourced in america yeah sure
it's tap local sourced in america yeah
they said it once on their own the whole
country and the whole it was hilarious
locally sourced in the whole yeah so
you're just giving this up again it's my
personal opinion i'm not a fan of
essentia so this is more just tap water
it's owned by nestle oh those [ __ ] so
this is they bought it last year
actually they bought it last year man
that water bit racket yeah that's huge
they called it they called it it's a
what they calling it uh
not a lifestyle a function water and i
think i said on my tick tocks or
somewhere on my social media like the
only function some waters have is there
the function is that you will pull out
the money from your from your wallet
right right so that's the only function
so this is basically here it says
purified water electrolytes for taste
9.5 ph yeah great that's incredible it's
just tap water you guys yeah it's
processed so when they say it has a high
ph what did they do to the water to
increase the acidity uh ionizing or
they're adding baking soda maybe some
companies as well to bring the ph up but
again it sounds like an interesting or
expensive process it's a marketing story
it's just [ __ ] it's a marketing
story and they make millions and
millions and millions of dollars i don't
know what but when i taste essentia and
that stuff it does taste like a little
crisper or is that just [ __ ]
i have no clue i refuse to drink
purified waters there you go because for
me
and i want to be clear that these water
brands are not bad for you it's not that
like essential smart water is bad
there are other tick talkers who think
like this kangan people that's a
different different topic kangen is a
multi-level marketing ionizing machine
um they are nuts these people in my
opinion on tech talk because they are
literally saying oh when you drink
essential you will be killed when you're
drinking smart water it's so bad i would
never ever say this because this is
crazy that's why i love it no that's why
that's why i ended up loving you so much
is because
you keep it real on everything correct i
don't like these brands not for the
quality of the water i don't like the
brands i don't like the business model
that is the product right i don't like
the business model that they're selling
you tap
that's the thing process tab
so what other what other uh waters do
you guys want me to fact check before we
get on i saw someone saying fuji that's
a popular one fiji yeah that's probably
the most popular one i'm seeing in the
chat it's actually a very good water
yeah
islands
is a a teasing spring so that means
artesian means there's so much pressure
on that spring source that the water
comes by themselves out of the spring
here it is um has a tds of 222 when you
think about smart water electrolytes
added around 36 tds this has 222. very
interesting way more
way more beautiful bottle too they
nailed the marketing yeah they did a
good job on that so here you can you
guys can see it says natural
artisan water teasing water correct
that's what you want to see on about
there you go there's a lot of silica
actually dissolved by nature silica is a
very interesting mineral what makes
water very very smooth so fiji has the
really cool effect on red wines when
you're drinking or when you're into red
wines or maybe acidic white wines when
we drink feature right next to it it
will lower the acidic levels of your
white wines and the bitterness of your
red wine the tannins will go away
and it feels rounder and easier to
swallow your red wines it's unbelievable
which you can actually do that's so
interesting a good water should pair
well and should not neutralize your pal
i have no clue who came up with this
idea of neutralizing the palette this
guy was stupid because when you're
paying a lot of money for your food and
when you're paying a lot of money for
your wine in the restaurant why should
neutralize it with a water to taste what
i just paid for no no i want a water
what helps the taste okay and minerals
doing this you know i'm so jaded that
when i see a bottle like this i say this
this has to be [ __ ] from the island
of fiji but it is it's the real deal
actually a real deal okay that's that's
good to know and then like non-expensive
ones i didn't brought them but for
example crystal geyser is that crystal
geyser is that totally good water really
arrowhead totally arrowhead see that's
what i wanted springs great water
arrowhead's my my that's so interesting
yeah i wouldn't expect this one to be
one of the good ones out there so it
doesn't don't don't believe this whole
marketing thing so this one says 100
mountain spring water here we go come
from a real spring storm and they can't
lie about that [ __ ] right i mean that's
false marketing that would be false
marketing uh some companies getting sued
right away when they're doing this so
there are people that lie about oh yeah
it's like the water industry is a messy
industry interesting let's face it it's
a messy industry look i'm i've been
involved in that whole industry for so
many years now again since 2005 and i
saw crazy things happening
like people making claims about craziest
things and then again some companies
suddenly some companies suddenly telling
like the weirdest stories i've been like
in an era one yesterday that's like a
super high expensive um market here in
los angeles they have like three stores
and they have auphora water what is
seems to be like santa barbara tap water
it's like twenty six dollars per house
or four and it's just tap water it's
like no and they're calling it obviously
they have all this nano
filtered and then
on this cellular level will hide which i
guess what every water will hate with
you on the cellular level because that's
what water does
it needs to bring nutrition to your
cells and need to get waste out of
yourself wow so don't say so there are
so many marketing lives when it comes to
water please be careful don't believe it
oh yeah do you know what diamond water
is
yeah i saw that ross actually yeah yeah
it was funny i talked about this
and it was on was this it's not from the
shores of sunset yeah yeah yeah i mean
and she thought like she put a diamond
on it or something or she she would run
the water over a diamond it's too much
for me like all this kind of stuff like
this whole crystals and
like when when i see like and nothing
against yoga people don't get me wrong
please but when i see a person doing
yoga right next to a water bottle and
tells you the positive energy will now
reflect the water right next to me and
this water has now positive vibes for me
and i can and this board is now a more
healing water to me i'm sorry um no no
that's why we just like i can't get it
we're getting a no on diamond water now
diamond water it says alkaline water
enhanced with real diamonds are we uh
and then people are suddenly starting
there's living in dead water you see
what the hell is that now
like living water that people really
believe when you're screaming now at
this bottle like when i scream out proud
source like hey proud what's up now this
water will not hydrate me anymore
and when i say
to
three base i love you you're so
beautiful it will hydrate you better
there are people out there who believe
this and put this on tick tock okay
that's that's yeah this is scary
and i call them out for that and this is
quite fascinating i just had a person
telling me no it's not about science
martin um
water has electricity and you need to
talk to electrician oh my god i just had
this four by five
for three days ago i think my tick tock
and i called it out for that like insane
people are you you have people getting
angry at tickling oh i love this yeah
you go you go
you go against the water crowd no i have
a lot of water companies getting angry
with me too yeah i know this oh really
oh i'm getting letters you ever get
legal threats from yeah that happens
look because obviously they're building
these marketing stories for years and
years this is expensive and suddenly
this german dude shows up
and tells like hey by the way it's
nothing other than marketing you gotta
say they don't like truth martin you're
they don't like one out there standing
against big water don't ever be
it's interesting to see these letters
now and obviously when i've received my
first letter i was like oh what the hell
right it's it's a it's a it's a weird
situation but but it's an insane thing
you know to sue for because it's
obviously protected speech i mean you
know yeah it's more personal yeah
exactly opinion what i'm saying here and
i can back it up because in a lot of my
tech talks i'm giving the reference to
universities when they're saying exactly
the same what i said for example the the
institute or the american institute for
cancer research is literally warning for
this whole alkaline diabetes that's so
interesting they're warning for it do
not fall for it so uh a couple i'm gonna
shoot a couple more at you and then
we'll do the taste test uh boxed water
smaller is better look at better
purified water this is green washing in
my opinion box water because green
washing oh yeah because it looks great
the box and you see oh there's no
plastic here trust me when this would be
just a box the water would come out
right away so they have they have linen
linings in there there's a wax liner oh
wax or plastic and the problem is with
these tetra pucks for example they are
barely recyclable in recycling
facilities versus plastic bottles and
aluminium bottles are way easier
recyclable it's all a gimmick
it's again the water industry is very
messy so this is purified water which
means just tap water yep wow box water
getting called out uh what else there's
actually nice people i have to say and
some water companies they connected to
me like hey martin we want to learn more
and this is actually nice box water
reached out to me once and said i want
to say this this is actually what i
honor on these they called me up and
said hey martin we saw your tick tocks
we saw you were against our water can we
please talk and i talked to them so this
is actually nice at least they're
engaging so what did they have to say
for themselves
that's the problem no it's like i don't
obviously i don't want to know it's a
con it's confidential talks obviously
what i have with them but they need to
understand what i'm doing it's like at
the end of the day if they're just
selling a marketing ploy and their box
isn't even that much more recyclable and
it's just tap water what do they have to
say correct yeah yeah that's problematic
yeah
their whole company is correct yeah no
absolutely i think so too but this is
millions dollars of worth of company
they're billions this whole water
industry is billions of dollars worth in
america that's so when i interrupting
that industry they're not everybody
happy with well people a lot of people
want to know about the sunny dasani is
ledge uh healthy legendary the worst
water people say ever made
look dazzani i did a tick tock yesterday
i was at downtown disney
and i think i said to the air i called
out disneyland and i said like hey
disney look at this i want to see what
kind of hydration i can get at downtown
disney so they had monster energy drinks
they had coke sprite diet coke and
dasani right these were the brands
in disney they only sell the sony water
and smart water i think oh it's smart
water right and i see topo chico now
what i think is considered actually a
good water from mexico
so
so i said to disney
it's all about characters for you you're
creating it's so amazing characters this
is all about your movies and then you
this completely bland water where has no
character whatsoever because again
dasani is nothing else than purified
highly processed tap water right from
the house of coca-cola
so i said it's not the happiest place on
earth i think disney's the scariest
place on earth when it comes to
hydration there it is
yeah
you heard it here let's debunk the mouse
is dead let's debunk a big myth about
yeah so everyone thinks it's salty
correct everybody thinks it's salty
because when you look at the back label
of dazani they're saying they're adding
salt it says here it says
it says enhanced with minerals for pure
freshness yeah it's a legal term they
have to say it so this every purified
water companies will say it they're just
stressing it but everybody thinks
obviously they're adding the
electrolytes for health benefits
completely bs so it's it's all about
taste so they're adding salt into it to
make this world kind of like tasty it's
kind of like cooking a soup again like
no salt super bland a little bit salt
tasty too much salt nobody wants to
drink it so dasani adds a little salt a
lot of people thinking because they're
seeing this and this does only gives
this dry mouth feel in the aftertaste
a lot of people are thinking they're
adding so much salt to make you
thirstier yeah by drinking and that is
actually a lie that is completely no no
that's not true
what do you think it makes the mouth dry
because they're adding so few
electrolytes oh it's not enough so it's
not enough so your body
you're starting to drink darzani water
will look for minerals because it's kind
of like off-balance now it will pour
minerality from your sliver and you have
this dry mouthfeel afterwards a lot of
people are asking your opinion on bong
water is that drinkable bong water yeah
i don't smoke
no but do but you can drink the water no
no no no no
and this is like this is what i always
say and this is maybe a big difference
to me and other tick tockers for example
somebody asked me martin what do you
think about baby formula water and i
said first of all i don't have babies um
my wife and myself were not really
interested in that whole thing she
thinks i'm baby enough for her so like
let's stop that whole idea of i have too
much energy for her and she's like nah
like this is enough for us so i was
reading up a lot of things and then i
saw different doctors talking about and
i thought you know what to go now out
there to tell on tick tock or something
that i would recommend this or that but
that's actually not my profession that's
not cool so i said on tick tock do you
know what i cannot say anything to that
and i think this is way better to
sometimes say that's just not my
expertise right i think this is way more
trustful to leave it to the doctors and
leave it to the doctors and this is what
i'm always saying whenever you're a real
professional when people are saying
martin i have kidney stones what kind of
water should i drink
talk to your doctor yes it's the same
your doctor you're not going to your
doctor and ask them what kind of red one
i should choose tonight for my steak
right that's my job as i saw you know
you re you're as real as it gets because
i feel like most people would take this
water thing and they would take it too
far and you know i don't want that i
want to be the real deal folks this is
mark but i'm getting thirsty we need to
drink some water okay so we've got the
whole let's do it so yeah so we have are
this a handful of like your favorite
waters or what how did you select i just
i just brought some waters i think they
are interesting from a taste perspective
from low tds to higher tds and i think
that would be interesting i brought some
waters i don't want to open some some
water you cannot even open because
they're 150 years old
um but i think it's kind of a cool
industry and story to tell for example
this one here
so this is a 150 year old water bottle
this is what use what water balls used
to look like clay there's no water in
there
but this comes from
yeah this comes from nida shelters it's
a little town in germany and when you
look at the label it says selters
and you know all heart cell tests these
days so your heart celtics are actually
named after a little small town in
germany all shelter all salsa so this is
real the real deal sells something this
is almost like an artifact you've got
here 150 years old pretty awesome and
they have a mineral water museum at that
little town and the mayor gave it to me
when i came oh my god very nice let me
ask you a question i've heard you saying
that there's such thing as naturally
carbonated water how does that happen
especially in areas where they had a lot
of big volcanic areas where co2 is
nestled literally trapped into different
stone layers got the bubbles and
everything yeah and water can be i
brought with you one that's crazy
carbonated carbonated water from nature
they're not adding it artificially to it
this is unnatural excited to try that
yeah well this is beautiful thank you
awesome
can you guys get a shot of all the
waters and stuff i want people to be
able to see the setup here so the thing
is before we starting to taste waters i
brought another brand because
and you can see how crazy this whole
water industry is and a lot of people
have literally no clue about water in
this country what it's actually said and
that's my my whole idea i want to bring
knowledge to people because the more you
know
the fewer you get scammed let's face it
we all know
knowledge is power and i want to protect
people
so
i've been on this down to earth with sac
efferent show with anna kendrick and zac
efron on netflix you can watch it right
now it's streaming right now so on the
second episode i did a water tasting and
there's one water that's called roy from
slovenia
and this has a tds of 7400 insane a lot
of minerals and has tons of magnesium
dissolved and i said on the soil this is
kind of like a municipal water so this
has actually a health benefit
now
to your well-being so nutrition called
me out for that in a newspaper and said
this is completely ridiculous what
martin is saying there is no municipal
water on this planet this is crazy how
can even netflix allowing this to say
this and i was like that is so funny
because she might be doesn't know does
not mean it doesn't exist
so i brought a bottle from germany
when you say
water what do you mean because it does
just mean local water no no not
municipal municipal what is this like
the this may be my accent again like
that hasn't health benefits oh it's
medicinal medicinal sorry about again
sorry guys sometimes my pronunciation is
so you're saying this water has health
benefits correct and then she said
that's both this is compliance because
it's water okay interesting interesting
so this is a natural occurring water
from germany they don't add anything in
there they're not allowed to do this
when it says natural water in germany
but this water when you look at this
closely here and you see this here
there's a number on it this is the
medication number of the german
government yeah this bottled water
actually falls under the medication law
and not under the bottled water
when you look at the back label it looks
like a medication back label because
they're trying exactly right how much
you have to drink for it what it does it
do and all this kind of stuff so yeah
there are over 60 brands on this planet
just in germany for example over 60
brands who falling underwater medication
so if it's a medicine what is a tree
it does for example you better um you
can better digest food for example or it
can fight kidney stones some water is
that right so there are several things
and it's not like that some holistic
doctor came up with this all this yeah
craziness no no we're talking about
scientific proven by the government
checked up scientific studies that these
waters have an impact when you're
drinking them and that is the
fascinating part so yes so yeah it's got
a medical on the back there is more to
water that's funny that you got called
out for a doctor because you're so legit
and i so let's try it yeah are we trying
this we're not trying this one i want to
try but no it's the only i got i
yeah it's a bottle i brought from
germany it's the only bottle i think in
the states right now really what you
cannot buy it's expensive no not at all
it's like two dollars in germany oh wow
bottled water in germany is super
unexpensive i did a tick tock where i
went to a german regular normal grocery
store and i looked at the water island
you see the price like three three
euros obviously four euros and everybody
thought like ah it's the same price
range no we're talking about a 12 pack
of glass bottles wow for three or four
dollars
i know there's a whole there's a robust
recycling system of glass bottles in
jeremy right so you actually people
actually return the glass bottles
everybody buys their crates of waters
you're taking this bottle you're
drinking them then you're taking the
bottles back in every grocery store they
have to recycle them back yeah you don't
have to go to recycling facilities i
spent i spent some time in germany and
that's one thing that actually surprised
me because in america it's just you use
you throw out nobody would throw this
but yeah glass bottles they drink sodas
they drink beers and everything
you bring the bottles back to where you
bought it yeah it's 25 cents recycling
fee so everybody thinks oh 25 cents to
throw them away that's a quarter
nap yeah like when you have 12 bottles
that's six bucks i don't know it's four
dollars obviously because that's money
yeah or three dollars sorry my mouth is
off today it's three dollars that's a
few bucks yeah that's a few bucks
interesting no but let's do some some
waters and i brought waters for
everybody guys because i want that oh
yeah yeah i want it like that's
important so the first one we're gonna
taste today proud sauce from from the
rocky mountain uh
uh coop kate says she's watching this on
mushrooms and it's blowing her mind i
love this
this is great anything you want to say
to calm her down happy hydration happy
height very important when you're on on
a little um
drugs mushrooms or whatever hydration is
the key absolutely we all know this
dehydration is something what is really
really bad people can actually die from
dehydration and very fast
marathon runners doing this all the time
or even on a radio show in 2006 happened
in sacramento they tried to drink i
don't know how much water they had the
whole idea of how much water can you
drink in an hour it's dangerous right
you can't have water poisoning water
poisoning and she passed away three
hours after this radio show i remember
that it was yeah they get charged yeah
yeah they get shot it was hold your pee
for a wee like they were trying to win
an unattended unbelievable what happened
there so what happens when you get water
poisoning are you aware or do you know
that so it's all yes it's all about the
electoral level so therefore water is
not just h2o good hydration is not just
taking water into your body because
where does water go and where does it
need to go it needs to go to the cell
and the cell just will get the water
when there's off balance of electrolytes
so that water will be absorbed to the
cell and will be released by the cell
and therefore it's magnesium calcium
sodium all these electrolytes are
essential for hydration so when you're
completely parched and you need like
really a lot of hydration it's not
healthy to drink two or three bottles of
water right away it's way better to
drink a bottle of water and eat an apple
because in that apple there's tons of
electrolytes and this is way healthier
for your body than just drinking water
so what killed her just because when you
get water poisoning you just drink too
much and it's taken away correct it will
talk all the salts out and this happens
as well with marathon runners when
they're sweating and sweating and
sweating and sweating and they're
drinking and drinking and drinking and
drinking water because the professional
water the professional marathon runners
they you don't see them drinking on
every little water station but they know
better
because the off balance of the
electrolytes in your body cannot
function anymore when you're off balance
of electrolytes it's super dangerous so
what do we have here so we have a
natural cooking water from the rocky
mountains i love these guys proud sauce
hold on it has an alkaline notice 8.5
doesn't mean for me that is bad natural
alkaline water can be interesting but
the idea they at least don't claim that
natural yeah that this does anything to
your body they're just saying it
but they don't say that's fair that
health benefits yeah it's it's fair
okay so so where's this one from it says
mineral and electrolyte water naturally
occurring
from where mccain is
what i think is cool about this little
company is
uh it was a mining town back in the days
mckay didn't have mining anymore they
thought like okay our town will
literally like everybody will move away
and they thought we have good water here
in the rockies why not starting a water
company to support the little town
and they made it it's really you can
find them now everywhere around the
states
it's a really cool company i met them
personally there's the nicest and
sweetheartedest people ever and i love
to work with people where actually
there's a passion behind it it's not
just a big corporation who has like some
excel sheets a little chalky in a good
way
i like this
right it's got a little something there
at the end it clearly has a little taste
profile yeah it lingers pretty long on
your palette it's not right away gone
like dasani sometimes does it doesn't
give you this dry mouthfeel it lingers
nicely but i like this water i think
it's a nice
daily hydration wall okay okay yeah and
how much does a bottle of that cost i
think two boxes two bucks there you have
it guys i think sorry i mean i'm sorry
i'm surprised i'm in dan loves it
absolutely very good very nice
okay tastes good
let's zoom is there a proper way to
taste water free base or is it just like
wine first of all i have them all in
room temperature that's i think the
first thing you maybe noticed okay um
because you want to taste actually
everything and when you would chill them
extremely down you can't taste anything
correct because you chill down your
palate
that's a problem that's the reason why i
think coca-cola always says please chill
me because we all know a warm coke
we don't want that uh three bays cool
story about them comes from down under
from the
from australia premium australian
mineral water three bays tds of 1 300.
that's pretty high right it's super high
almost unheard of for still water to be
that high and so this is going to have
more of a flavor because it has higher
it even has a different texture i think
oh my god it really does
and this crazy how heavy that water is
you're right it's almost like olive oil
you're right it's very thick it's the
funny thing about them is that's very
interesting that water when i think
about age of water you always know every
water is super old because the water
cycle oh my god um this water is kind of
like 2 000 years so that means when it's
rained water and the rain comes down to
the ground that's for me when i'm saying
when i'm saying it's an aged water so it
takes 2 000 years to pass through all
the different mineral levels wow until
it comes up by a spring source that's
the reason it has so much minerals
dissolved wow um think about this last
time that was rainwater was pretty much
when jesus was still floating around
here it's pretty good pretty awesome
interesting water it definitely has a
very unique taste oh clearly which is
real really interesting i'm always
thinking it's a lot of hate relationship
water guys are saying we love it some
people oh my god uh a lot of people are
saying liquid death i see you brought a
candidate yeah but we'll open a new one
um what's real interesting i think
americans specifically are so used to
drinking this purified water like i've
never i don't think i ever taste the
water like this neither it's real heavy
it's very thick yeah i would have
i would have laughed at the idea of
somebody trying to tell me that that
water is thick 100 percent after tasting
this this water is out there thick water
this is thick water
we all agree with you
because i would have on face value said
this water is such [ __ ] and the more
i watch i was like this guy actually is
talking about some [ __ ] and uh well and
again i totally get it when you when
again when you're watching my dicks i'm
telling you about all the different
flavors and what and you're like what
the hell is he talking about what you
just mentioned yeah when you're doing it
right now here by yourself then you're
like oh my god so the only thing i
actually sell on my on my social media
accounts are water boxes so you can go
into my link tree and i'm sending you
six different waters oh work and then
i'm doing online water classes that can
take me to online and i'm doing this
what's your website uh martin minus
reason.com
mark what's your last name but actually
go not go to my home page go to nick's
waters so go to my social media whatever
take instagram tech talk and there's a
link tree someone sent me seven and
seven of the link tree and then i'll let
let's go
yeah and then you can actually buy a
water box from me curated with six oh
awesome and then you can actually you
can tie them by themselves there's a
little note to it you can try them by
yourself or you can book actually an
add-on where i'm going on a zoom with
you oh you know with like 20 30 people
and we're doing a tasting together well
i think there's going to be a lot of
people interested in this so that's
actually really cool people are going to
really like this i think you're going to
get a lot of interested people here so
if you go to his link tree you can we'll
put this in the description and you guys
put that in the chat i just put in the
chat yep so here it's just link tree dot
martin reese r-i-e-s-e
here is his thing again we'll put the
put the link in the description for
anyone that wants to check it out
and then what do we go to the home page
no home page virtual water tastings
event then first you get your tasting
box no it was like
wonderful look at this guy here we go
a hydrated one
man
this is so cool what you're doing i
gotta say
i go back on the link tree and then
thirsty get your tasting box from martin
here okay yeah the tasting box there we
go okay very cool very cool click on
this is the one we just tried three bay
correct
and it's always switching out i always
like think what i'm getting like what
kind of interesting brands i have and
you can book this the problem is and i'm
so sorry guys i think i'm charging 35 or
something for the tasting box but the
problem is it's heavy it's glass bottles
insane shipping is insane
so
i'm sorry guys it's not like that i'm
making tons of money with this because
there's tons of work to put all these
water boxes together yeah um shipping is
super expensive like an additional 30
bucks yeah water yeah makes sense i'm
sorry again i would love to get it
cheaper for you guys and because i
strongly believe you should open a water
store yeah something like this i'm
really thinking about maybe to um
we will see i wonder if that would be a
hit a water store yeah why not why not
people who maybe saw this right now i
opened sukkosani from peru and it says
still water so what do you make what
they say superior mineral mineral water
okay superior premium that's all
marketing which is [ __ ] that's
that's that's marketing words and i
understand this but sukkosan is actually
a very cool interesting one peru
peruvian andes mountains has a tds
similar to uh three base a little bit
higher actually of 1390
okay wow pretty high as well yeah the
interesting part is you sit here on the
bottle
it's still
it's carbonated really carbonation in
there that's 100 calories this is an
effervescent water
this is a still water by regulations but
there's tiny tiny bubbles in there this
is crazy
when you pour this you see it as well
there are some bubbles but this is their
still version so is this what you would
consider naturally naturally carbonated
i would call it natural effervescent
water it's like super low because now
boy the second zip you barely have the
carbonation so everything is like a step
below definition it's like super low try
that is that crazy super interesting
that's so nuts dude this kind of i
wanted to ask because um until now we've
been talking primarily uh still water
but what are what's your thoughts on on
bubbly water now the three next one are
bubbles okay you love bubbles
you're down with bubble water and it's
just
bubble water hydrates the same
absolutely it's a myth guys don't
believe the crazy ones on tick tock who
telling you when you're drinking acidic
water or carbonate water you you're
gonna die in the next two years it's all
nonsense so lacroix if you drink a la
croix it's just the same as drinking a
glass of water
yeah la croix obviously is adding
other stuff because taste flies yeah
yeah yeah i'm not a big fan of lacroix
because purified again no there's other
things so i think when you want to have
taste in your bottle
a lemon taste or something like this get
yourself a good spring water a good
mineral water where carbonaceous and
then squeeze yourself a nice lemon into
it way healthier because then you're
getting actually nice minerals and
vitamins as well by the way that is my
favorite one that is so nice i'm into it
i can't believe that's awesome
great water huh yep very very versatile
but again very small how much people i
have no clue we don't have maybe
is it weird to say it's kind of sweet
like it's a little bit he likes this no
i think it's it's it's the same with
fiji fiji's slightly sweetest one the
aftertaste and i think sukhosan is the
same when you don't like acidic waters
when they're like a lot of carbonation
in it we have one vichy is very intense
later on and you like them more like
super mild
i'm gonna piss myself so i'm gonna yeah
no no absolutely i'm gonna dump it the
extra that's a different fetish what we
don't want to discuss today
[Laughter]
i'm german huh we're like yeah
is it true about the
we hear about injury there's so much
crazy stuff going on in germany john you
don't even wanna
but hey but this is the cool thing we
are at least we talk about this in
german and we are easy and we are like
fine with that
and this is so strange when it comes
obviously a little off topic right now
but but here in in in america everybody
is so uptight when it comes to sexuality
i have no clue what's going on like you
can show boobs in germany that's totally
normal
like i said one of the things that blew
my mind i was like i was
18 years old watching tv late at night
and there was tits bro everywhere wasn't
even newspapers so this is liquid death
this is actually one i've been seeing
around i didn't know was sparkling water
so is this natural they have something
sparkling this is added carbonation oh
this is added straight from the alps yep
it comes from the from the austrian alps
so it's mountain water they also say we
donate 10
of all the profits
to help kill plastic pollution
what i like wow there are some water
companies having uh like this giving
back and i like this i think it's a
great good course i'm working for
example with viva con aqua it's a
non-profit organization out of germany
and we're trying to raise money to help
people in need and they're taking the
money not giving it to our government
because they're taking the money and
building their own team and building
wealth where people don't have access to
clean safe drinking water i think that
is a cool thing when you go to my tech
talk or my instagram you see supporting
viva con aqua it would be means a lot to
me guys when you maybe have two or three
dollars for them
uh to help others because again it's a
privilege what we're doing here guys so
this is this is from austria i know it's
the liquid death now when you talk about
these like 2 000 year old water from for
example australia the one that i that
was heavy we described how do they mine
that water how did they access that
water it's so funny i know olaf the
owner very well from three base
and he told me this story when when he
discovered this water it was by accident
so
he bought a house with a nice land and
he was wondering why are all the
kangaroos
like hanging out at this little like
thing there down there we walked down
there and realized there's a spring
source natural springs was coming coming
up a little well of water yeah a little
well of water and the and the kangaroos
were drinking this and he thought like
oh that's kind of cool to have my own
water but obviously we don't know if
this is safe to drink that's what i
highly recommend everybody as well
please guys don't go just to the rivers
when maybe water looks great does not
mean it's safe right they could be
bacteria what you cannot see
microbacteria is actually a thing like
it's like please don't do that you gotta
boil the water yeah yeah please boil the
water or let it check out like don't
think oh it comes from a river now we
are back to nature and it's also cool i
see again tick-tock us all the time
doing this the thing is animals drink
that but their stomachs we are not
evolved to live in the water
like that their stomachs kill
that bacteria right please don't it can
be maybe great but it can be very poison
to you too yeah it can make you very
correct so please don't do there you go
martin here don't do it in fact
so i like this one i like it you know
so how did they mine it though so he's
got a little spring there and then they
just set up like a well right so they
they realize that they send it over to a
lab to make sure it's actually safe to
drink yeah and they found this very
unique water because the lab said like
oh my god they're like 27 key minerals
is dissolved in your water that's reason
so thick as well as tons of minerals
dissolved interesting awesome so they
build obviously a little facility around
that that they can now
get that water into the bottle it was
just on his land that was on his land
wow they found a bike so how interesting
it's cool i i've been to several springs
where they literally headed by accident
i have a it's a there's a spring source
in germany it's called radius 99. it's
super small that means the name made
after the radius just 99 kilometers in
that area they are supporting and
distributing this water but they don't
believe in shipping water from a to b
because obviously we all know
it's a problem for the environment and
i'm clearly about this and for sure some
people had a comment already this is
insane to bring a fiji bottled water
from a to b uh it's like my thousands of
miles away but let's face it
where does your red wine comes from
maybe the french bordeaux is great as
well you cannot get the same quality and
maybe in california so it's the same
with water and this is i think it needs
to be a balance when you just want to
hydrate yourself please string fill the
tap i cannot stress it enough do not buy
bottled water when you don't care about
taste but when you feel about taste
sometimes it's cool filtered water is
totally fine you just don't like that
they're
scamming people don't buy it in a store
got it got it that's just insane and can
people can you over
mine a natural spring like how do these
guys in australia with this spring we
were talking about he found it by
accident on his property how does he
make sure he doesn't over mine in many
many countries it's forbidden by law to
overmine
the waters okay and then they've been
checked out by the government all the
time for example in europe when you see
a european brand you you can be certain
it's
it's sustainable sourced because it
happened just with bad work
is an incredible amazing cool sparkling
water from from france
and i love that water and you could find
it pretty much in a lot of restaurants
suddenly in los angeles and for around
two years ago they stopped selling it
here in the states and i was asking i
was calling like the company saying
what's up guys
what's happening saying yeah climate
change is real i think what does that
mean yeah it doesn't rain so much
anymore in france it's getting warmer
and warmer so the spring source does not
provide so much water anymore so we had
to stop selling
in several countries so when you want to
have bad water you can just exodus right
now in france wow
that's crazy
scary but i like liquid they did a good
job on their marketing obviously but
it's actually a real water from a real
natural current source has had tds of
170 what is again way more electrolytes
than essential smartphones for example
pretty awesome wow
[Music]
i love that uh that light the
effervescent one is still my favorite
is insane yeah it's insane
no it is okay that's insane peru is
great
very interesting water from spain so i'm
calling somebody was asking about this
water in the chat oh yeah yeah we have a
water connoisseurs in chat we have
apparently a lot of water connoisseurs
in the chat
so what do we have here so this is a
high content mineral water from spain a
little bit northern of barcelona so it
says carbonated mineral water isn't that
properly carbonated
dude that is so cool oh well so this is
very interesting
it has a lot of sodium oh yeah over a
thousand milligrams of sodium in a liter
this is kind of nuts one serving of this
water is 18 of your daily sodium i have
never seen that in my life this is great
for people who like extremely exercise
okay right
right you're maybe in in the heat wave
you need to hydrate yourself that thing
has tons of minerals dissolved wow
that is very interesting that's like a
sports drink it's without it's like
gatorade without the sugar without the
sugar and from nature
that is a cool thing and that is what
water does there's so much difference i
would have never dreamed in a million
years you could just pull this out of
the earth you guys i can't describe it
it's like
a flavorful carbonated
it's crazy you taste the sodium oh yeah
100 yeah super good though i like it
very good i was on the corner brian show
for several years ago and he spilled it
out he's like come on man you give me
ocean water he's being dramatic it
tastes amazing i love that he's just
trying to be funny this and reposado
tequila
unbelievable you make them to mix that
it's insane it's like a cocktail by
himself oh that's like awesome it's not
enough suddenly getting from this
reposado you're getting something this
caramel notes
and you know caramel and salt is pretty
awesome that is mind-blowing this and
reposado insane i think i'm going to be
buying some artisan water after this
which is kind of insane to say you know
when this one hits your tongue it's like
you want it to be a gatorade it tastes
like almost like the first sip of a
gatorade absolutely or like when you get
a mouth full of the ocean
a little bit also
i'm not getting ocean vibes but the
tedious of ocean waters
33 000 a little high we don't want to
drink right right because that is like
our
procession and filter the high content
of that tedious therefore ocean water
would be actually poison for us can i
ask you what do you think about
desalinated water that's an interesting
new development yes and it's very
important i'm a big supporter for this
and i know
israel i was in israel for four years
ago i have a water company over there
and first of all i love that country
unbelievable i never been to israel i
had the best time ever i was in tel aviv
wow i don't know if you know my wife is
real no i know you know okay uh i blew
my mind yeah and i was at the holy wall
and for me i had one of the most
i think one of the most interesting
scenarios in my whole life
i was standing there at the holy wall
and obviously i'm german so i know the
pressure of history was putting on to my
onto me because i know obviously what my
grand grand grand now not that old i'm
not that old or like he's not at all but
like what
the four bears two generations prior to
me did right huh so i know this and what
we what my generation does nowadays
we have to make sure it will never
happen again from germany in in general
something terrible and disgusting and
whatever that was it was obviously
crazy maniacs who was running germany
so i was there and watching the people
washing themselves on this two big like
it was not spring sauce but they had
like this fountains and they had like
very interesting they washed their hands
with water before and cleaning
themselves before to pray
and i was standing there as a water
swampy and this was for me one of the
most fascinating parts in my life
interesting to see the scenario of
engagement to water and religion
i enjoyed this there's a there's a they
do that a lot it's part of the ceremony
of
certain uh holidays where you bring a
bucket and you have to wash your hands
just ceremonially you know i like this i
think it's great this is like this is
showcasing the yeah there it is it's
yeah correct it was right there so you
fill up the you know the bucket and then
you just kind of rinse your hands and
for me this is what we all should do we
should honor water
and i know it's kind of strange because
we have a very strange relationship to
water in general we're all humans
because the first thing how we're
engaging with waters we are peeing and
go ahead say it and [ __ ] on it thank
you martin you know on a daily basis
right so it's kind of strange what do
you do are you opposed to pissing and
[ __ ] water i'm not exposed but i
think there's new technologies and we
all know this when we're going to
restrooms these days there's no urinals
where they don't use water and you know
what i think it's the first great step
how do we get rid of [ __ ] without
running water it's gonna be tough yeah
it's gonna be tough yeah
yeah yeah because um clean ass is a good
ass let's face it we and you know do you
use a bidet martin
i saw you with ac i love that you use a
bidet
let me ask you this you shower with
purified water does your [ __ ] get
squirted with purified water i have a
home filtration system so everything oh
yeah my man
you got a nice moisturized [ __ ] hey
everybody i feel very comfortable right
now
[Laughter]
so um
wow look we're having fun that's good
i have one more and this is a german
brand it's called nevers water but i
want and this is a water this is not
about hydration anymore now okay this is
a water that whole idea about that is
it's more like a celebration ward and i
think it was great to to just show the
from the bottom yeah what we just saw in
in jerusalem it looks like champagne
it's packaged yeah when people are
honoring water and let's face it there
are people out there who don't drink
alcohol these days for religious reasons
or for health reasons or just they don't
like the taste so they're millions
actually out there and why not when they
want to celebrate new year's eve or
christmas or something what are they
going to cheers with so this is what is
table water it's a sparkling coconut
that is a very interesting part so this
water comes from two different
mineral spring sources in germany but
the regulations are so strict in germany
that they're saying when you're calling
it
natural spring water it has to come from
one single cell okay interesting this
comes from two so this is the first
couvey water the same what wine people
doing they're mixing for example a melo
with carbon e4
together and then they're creating a new
taste profile
they're doing that with two different
spring stores to create a new taste
of the balance of the different minerals
the tedius is 2 000. that's right is
that the highest we've tried no the
vichy is the highest with 3 000 now this
looks expensive how much does this is
this run i think this is like 30 or 40
bucks okay wow per bottle so that's
again this is not hydration anymore and
don't think it comes on this box uh this
is the limit edition what they're having
five hundred dollars really
what i brought today
so we're gonna drink this yes yes
but this is a limited edition this is
number one
from the yeah
from 2019 whoa got the mickey swag
ironic they have the worst water uh in
the world
theoretically it's very interesting yeah
here they are on this bottle
wow it's pretty cool i like i like the
magnum so 1.5 liters we have the
swarovski crystal the bleeding version
as well where they were on the corner
where the camera is because the green
screen is actually keying it out a
little bit oh here we go you guys can
see this interesting art
it's a nice bottle nice very nice and
again it has nothing to do with
hydration anymore guys this is nothing
now don't think like oh my god martin
tells us we need to buy 30
worth of one bite of water completely
nonsense this is something you want to
celebrate but you don't want to drink is
this the same water that's in there
exactly this is just a limited edition
that's the limited edition that students
is that a rolex crown on the other side
of it uh no it's their their house crest
oh okay you're talking about uh
this no no no the uh
steel here yeah uh oh this one yeah i
think so yeah it's a relic it's the
artist
um went nuts a little bit there so here
let's uh yeah so get a load of this guys
we got the uh it's must be really
carbonated it's interesting obviously
classic case
it's bottled like champagne but this can
happen and you can see even a water
swimmer here sometimes cannot even open
their own bottles because now
it broke it broke that little thing and
i cannot open it do we have a plier uh
pliers we need something yeah we got you
unfix this yeah
what happens if this happens at a table
what are we doing on a regular basis
when i'm working the restaurant i always
have my wine key with me but
then i wouldn't i wouldn't bring it
today to the podcast because i literally
didn't thought that this could happen i
want my money back but this kind of
happens
even with a regular champagne it can
happen
so but that thing will pop
it's gonna be fun so it's very
carbonated yeah
it's like like champagne
and
so
is this a popular water or is this kind
of underground it's underground yeah
many many waters what i showcased today
which is pretty big in in spain it's the
number one consumed spanish water in the
catalonia area oh wow okay so they're
drinking this all and and vichy yes is
pretty heavy in taste but when you're
eating for example barbecue having a
nice steak or something like that or
short ribs on your grill
and then you're drinking vichy
unbelievable good
it's really cool it's not that salty
anymore suddenly what is very unique
it's very nice
yeah while we
no not a wine player that we can
something that we can unwire this here
yeah i got pliers yeah that would be
amazing
or maybe a
knife or so tell me you can get this off
when did you move to america
uh
2011. and what brought you very perfect
thank you dan so i haven't
water actually brought me over i have an
o1 visa for extraordinary abilities
really
dang i think i'm the only guy on the
planet dude yeah yeah just correct
but then i can open it
so
it i know it's not easy to get those
visas was it hard to prove that you're
actually a watcher here uh 400 page
position uh interviewer at the consulate
in berlin because i was still in germany
back in the days and they all looked at
me like i'm almost like the craziest
person they ever met right but they
never had an one visa for water tank for
water and a regular base to to get
people like an idea what 01 means
it's it's like the albert einstein visa
so when you when you're like a actor and
you're applying for the one you better
win the oscars or the emmys when you're
a scientific person
you better be uh have a nobel prize or
something like this so you have to reach
the top of your field
then you're considered one potential
right just two percent of all visas been
issues by the american government are
all ones that's incredible that is
incredible i have it on water so um
was it perfect the pro did you work with
a lawyer or did you write oh yeah no no
i had to work
so did the lawyer be like what you can't
do this when you came to them
he came up with the idea oh really he
said my immigration lawyer said martin
everything what you do there in germany
is quite fascinating you wrote a book
about water you're doing so many things
already in germany about water so it's
not an la thing because a lot of people
always thought when i came oh my god la
has our waters from a classic l.a that's
such la thing yeah i know i did this
already since 2005 in germany that's not
a la thing
let's open this i gotta pause let's
celebrate hopefully nothing will like
explode here but i think that would be
fun oh let's be good i think so too huh
hopefully the dogs won't go nuts there's
nothing
here we go
to water
okay
so this is the most expensive bottle
we've tried right yeah yeah yeah and
again and thank you thank you by the way
for sure definitely
cheers and again price does not matter
about quality i don't want that you're
taking away the things like oh my god
there's just trying all this expensive
stuff and good water needs to make sense
it does not need to be expensive guys i
cannot stress it enough hmm
now is this uh naturally carbonated
no no they're adding it to as well
but i like that
the carbonation is
it's intense in the beginning but it's
actually then very easy to swallow it's
not that expressive anymore like a
parrier for example it's like very in
like these other waters have like tons
of carbonation now you said pear i've
heard you say perrier
is naturally carbonated
that's incredible i don't know why that
just is so crazy to me is a good water
i like piggy
very nice
this is very carbonated yeah that's very
nice oh yeah yeah
that's the idea of champagne i like that
this
heavier carbonation you want to pop it
open this is like it's a pretty cool
water i love that oh that's good it like
disappears in your mouth that's some
good water folks ooh
melts in your mouth
very good
cheers martin cheers my friend to a one
of a kind
and i gotta say
what an interesting guy thank you for
coming and sharing your story with us
always here for you and you know
everybody oh i want there's one more i
wanted to ask you about black water
you've seen that stuff yeah and what's
the story there they have two sources
black water one of the bottles that are
saying that spring sauce the other one
is purified and again i'm not into
purified so therefore
i don't know it's actually black though
what's that like there's i'm not 100
even sure
how they're adding this
volvic trace minerals correct yeah
um
it's a water beverage it's not a water
in my opinion anymore at this point yeah
it's a near water product okay and
i don't have any feelings to them okay i
gotta be neutral but you know i just got
to give it up because you really
you really blew my mind and just turned
upside down something that i would have
thought was so ridiculous
and i'm i've actually learned something
really incredible and new
and i have a new respect for water i
gotta to save and i'm a very cynical
person i really am it's true i am one of
the most i really am some say the most
cynical but i gotta say but ethan
overall the whole idea what i'm doing
it's literally it's not just about
drinking water to be fancy here in the
studio and like oh my god there's so
many different tastes it's all about
hey when we know
water has taste we start maybe to
rethink
our use of water because suddenly water
has value because we're not just
thinking oh just tap or just water right
and my hashtag is always water it's not
just water
there's so much more to discover and
we're starting to rethink water when
we're starting to respect water we may
be helping others to gain access to
clean safe drink water and we're helping
our environment maybe to make a little
bit better choices too to select the
right waters for us too
so that's that's the key here and and
i'm always seeing in in the
in the last thing of my tick tocks
remember water is not just water and
stay hydrated my friends and i want to
say to everybody as well stay hydrated
that's the most important thing love
each other and be hydrated um beautiful
message big water fan here
would love martin's opinion on hawaiian
volcanic water great one
is that the actual name of the brand
yeah hawaiian volcanic water there's
another one why ikea great water very
nice water then um what's the hector
name
what's
aquaman so bad at that
so he's supporting a water brand right
now i don't even know what the water
brand's called anymore i did a tech
trick about it and when you think he's
from hawaii and they have such amazing
cool great waters
i don't understand the concept why he
supports now a water brand what is
nothing else and highly precise i know
why and not even from hawaii it's from
somewhere else i know why it's so
strange they've paid them a shitload of
money yeah maybe yeah
it's for me like and that's that's
i'm saying no to water companies i'm
very selective this is a mana
mana aloo
i don't know what it is uh let's
unplastic our planet okay
yeah but then drink tap that's all yeah
drink tap water yeah so we don't even
need that waste
oh that's true right pure purified 12
pounds
and the name is terrible and the bottle
who came up with that terrible
marketing design like nobody can read
that
it comes like really the fact it
conjures a feeling of hawaii
but it's actually not even bottled up
but then look look at wayak here
from hawaii what they did through their
aluminium bottle way nicer waiakia
so much nicer
i have no idea how to spell that no why
are you with a w
oh thank you dan
yeah so here is an actual wall and
that's actually a real water from a real
source
here yeah beautiful and look at their
aluminium bottle
they have pt and aluminium but the
aluminum bottle they knocked it out now
they say healthy what do you think about
that planet sure every water every water
is healthy yeah exactly
yeah that's a bit again
every every water will hydrate you
huh like this whole
there you have it well i gotta say
love that martin thank you so much for
taking the time guys if you if you're
interested in following martin we're
going to drop his link tree and chat
it's in the description in the
description and and a link to his tick
tock and his youtube channel yeah
appreciate all the love what a joy
everybody thanks for all the support
here thank you so much wow what a
pleasure thank you so much thank you
i think everyone's running to go pee now
oh yeah we'll help uh pack all that up
there all right
thank you thank you
oh
i gotta say one of those waters
i think i'm gonna buy
i have what what was the naturally
carbonated one
yeah was that the one that i liked
sukasani
dude you got to get on that sukkasani
but i know the owners very well oliver
so let me know and i'm for sure i can
connect you with them i could get it on
tap you know but don't don't buy it
extremely expensive in the store let me
see if i look on amazon sokasana
it's running uh
for
30 bucks
yeah that's the reason don't don't think
amazon wait 30 bucks for eight
holy [ __ ] get it before better
holy [ __ ]
all right there you go guys water is not
water
absolutely wow
well i do have to pee really bad
i had that before martin came and now i
really have how bad you have to pee
right now really bad um
i gotta tell you yes we've been going
for about two hours and 17 minutes is
that right
there is something that i cannot talk
about on air that is happening in about
15 minutes um
preparation for an episode later this
week
in 15 minutes uh
to me on discard
is it the thing
the thing
so the thing for tomorrow yes
[ __ ] things they got a job they got
to do that right now uh well they're not
here yet but they we have a huge episode
planned this week
yep huge huge
massive undertaking
i'm not announcing it
i do have to pee though well maybe maybe
we'll do i don't know
there's so much more to talk about i
mean that martin conversation was
fascinating it ended up going
for for longer than i thought it would
but i knew he was going to be great i'm
telling you he's yeah no that martin he
ruled and
genuinely uh you know i'm cynical like
you i've always wanted i'll drink
whatever water i don't care
um
those were some of the best waters i've
ever had in my life very unique he knows
what he's talking about he's a badass
dude dude he's [ __ ] him all the year
it's like shout the [ __ ] out dude
and i love that he just talks [ __ ] on
all these shitty waters too he doesn't
pull back i gotta pee um i'll be right
back in the meantime
uh
i guess i'll just be right back you guys
don't leave don't leave please
[Music]
what are you guys doing today anyone
here from arizona well here we are again
here i got something i want to say
i want to shout out dan
who after work on friday spent his whole
friday helping me build a pc
he gave up his weekend for me he helped
me build a pc what a legend
shout out to you
i told you how to help yeah you did you
did but we didn't expect to be here
until like 11 o'clock at night well
she's honestly uh dan
i think to be honest i somewhat expected
that just because uh
i've been down that road before and when
you're building a computer there's
always
complications uh snags all that kind of
stuff um but uh
built my pc2 back in the day oh i didn't
know right that's right
actually wow
yeah well i'm glad you did because i
would have definitely messed that up
thank you sure dan's gonna build a
guitar for me actually yeah i've
actually
zach and i went out last weekend uh for
a walk through the woods walk in the
woods uh-huh we uh found a dead dog i
found a uh the dollar and i also found a
nice um
a nice maple mmm yeah that we're going
to go back out there we're going to chop
that and uh we're looking for some alder
an older body yeah you know love
you wrangling gators over there
oh yeah brother
what the hell you did re-doing boy
these these darn guard ratsicles
uh dan saved me from a fire that's right
you're welcome carla
oh god don't play that oh
don't play that
stop
stop
we haven't even introduced that we
haven't even it's a secret what it is so
maybe
let me see we got all kinds of messages
flowing in here let's see what we got to
say checking in from arizona there you
go there is someone here
way too damn hot yeah i believe it i
believe it glitch2d
welcome someone please tell zach he
looks like
ko wetzel laughing my ass off
k.o.e
wetzel
[Music]
let's take a look at co wetzel
what do you think
yeah
a little bit sure that guy [ __ ] dude
i see it that guy [ __ ] i'll take it as
a compliment thank you i think it is a
compliment yeah this is a handsome man
that guy [ __ ] hard dude
i got it i gotta gotta give a shout out
to oreo and chad who's been donating or
giving so many subs probably over three
four hundred at this point oh my god no
what 200 at least 200 at least no way
and then we have p
from this was actually during the
chelsea manning show so i was able to
give them shout outs right
uh p also donated probably three
possibly 400 uh like uh subscriptions
it's crazy
shout out
the [ __ ] out god baby damn shout out to
their family
uh global warming is real howdy from
texas what's up
oh he's back dan saved me from burning
building hello much love from greece
just born burning through these real
quick born and raised in florida for 16
years brother haters is overrated
help me put gators in arizona uh yes
somebody said that uh zach uh looks just
like him oh that guy [ __ ] dude
yeah i'm getting a zack vibe for sure
yeah i'll definitely see that what are
that one in the bottom left that's the
most sack vibe
uh-huh
dude i want a picture with this guy i
want to collab with this like he's
wearing your jacket and any glasses in
there i wanna co
shout out my guy let's need a collab man
let's get this happening dude cold wet
so if you're watching this come on yeah
dude let's let's uh let's get down to it
man that was such an interesting uh
interview
yeah so cool
all right well let's let's get it oh
shredder all right over there yeah he's
he's just gone
he's wearing your jacket glasses sorry
so let's see we got a lot to get to
still
apparently we've been going a while yeah
we are somewhat limited on time here so
maybe what's what's the best juice you
got
all right let's take a look we've got um
dude i gotta watch this i don't care
i just don't care this is the best thing
you guys we followed the fika fish
okay we saw that english dude
eat it
then we saw shoe nice eat it
both champions right in their own right
shoe nice took the cake for the ultimate
fika fiend
yet here enters a new challenger
mukbang food and this girl's face i mean
what what's happened to her face
is that a filter or makeup or why does
she look like that
it looks like a filter
filter yeah and that could be a dude for
all i know like those filters are so
crazy oh yeah like i i don't know if you
guys remember this story about the
japanese biker guy oh yeah
he literally just turned himself into a
cute girl and got all popular
well whoever this person is
they're an
absolute icon
i have never seen
a feat like this in my life ever
it's amazing
i mean this did this blow your mind love
oh yeah i mean i get tagged in all these
swedish swedish stuff on tick tock and
you know i usually like just shrug my
shoulders but this this got me [ __ ]
i don't know what to say at this i
couldn't eat i watched this i lost my
appetite ian as someone who's eaten the
fish
uh as our residents fika fish champion
what did you have you seen this
yeah unfortunately and what was your
what kind of emotions did you experience
sort of
uh like the walls were closing in on me
i you know was transported back to a
time i did not want to relive
i was having flashbacks for sure
but you respect her right i mean
i never yes in a twisted way yes so here
she is the undefeated
she got some rice down there to make it
like more palatable i guess two cans of
it
i just can't just oh my god
dude seriously if you've ever smelled
this she's gagging
if you've ever smelled this you could
you i can't even fathom sitting in front
of that much of that
with the juice and everything
and i think it's like minced or
something
yeah i can't watch this you guys don't
understand what she's doing if you've
never eaten this
oh my god oh my god oh my god
is that the same brand we got
yeah
oh my god you guys there are different
brands yeah it looks like the same brand
but like a different cut this is right
shredded or something this one doesn't
matter
oh my god you guys she's drinking it you
don't understand how [ __ ] up this is
like if you've smelled this this is it's
subhuman this is freak [ __ ] this woman
is not human
oh my goodness oh diarrhea i mean it's
looks like she's
oh my god oh my god oh my god oh my god
oh my god oh my god oh my god
dude shoe nice is nothing shoe nice is a
peasant
oh my god you guys
oh my god how how
what if you're forced to do this i i
can't believe what i just watched
how i can't describe to you guys how
[ __ ] that is
so this is the fico world champ i don't
think anyone could ever top that
like
if there was someone who thought the
fika fish tasted like pumpkin pie i
don't think they could top that you know
what i mean i i just don't know what
type of mental state you could go in to
do that like no meditation can put you
to drink that [ __ ] well this woman is a
superstar i think we need to keep a
closer eye on her
because she's up to all kinds of crazy
shenanigans
um on her
page
oh golly is it off the screen
let's see okay what is this like you
know what i mean like what the [ __ ] even
is that like sausage casing like look at
this i mean this woman is an absolute
another level
this is just i'm telling you we gotta
keep an eye on her
is that like is that is it like a squid
or something
it's no it's just sausage
but i never seen sasha's that thick
that's like straight up large and
destined bro right that's like a fat
dookie right there dude
oh dude she's so gnarly nothing grosses
her out man
oh my god i wonder if she eats ass
oh my god she's probably a
champion monster ass here for sure i'm
telling you this girl
we got to keep an eye on her she's up to
good great things
[Music]
[Applause]
holy smokes man what even is that dude
what is it
i'm trying to there's no [ __ ]
what the [ __ ] is that
wait what is happening what are those
what the
yeah it's just peach it's just a peach
a little change of pace for her
from from intestines to
okay but what is this
squid probably
dude of course fika fish wouldn't face
her she is
but it did face her that kind of makes
it worse almost she's just in pain doing
it look at this
this woman is a threat to ocean
sustainability
[Music]
yes keep an eye on her you guys i'm
telling you
she's a rising star
there you have it fika fish champ
someone tells shoe nice he's been
dethroned not even close
if shoe nice needs to if he wants to
beat that he's got to really step it up
drinking the liquid
unheard of
un
[ __ ] heard of i i mean
ian would you take a shot of the liquid
for for the right price
let's let's have this
we just talked about beautiful water
liquid and hydration let's save this for
what fifa fish juice isn't uh it wasn't
beautiful pure
purified water
yeah i don't know the ph of all that
electrolytes right right right
there you have it
god damn it
well what's in the title what do we need
to talk about oh the debate let's do
that
all right
people are hotly debating this video
so we're going to debate it here we're
going to do a poll so everybody
pay close attention the question is
who is right and who is wrong in this
video
um listen
this guy goes up to a ice cream store
one minute before it closes
they refuse to serve him
but he's there before closing
technically even if just by a minute
because i'm making ice cream listen i
came out to finish you walked down
we can't let
customers shut the door just like you
were but we were all busy
there's a sign on the door that says
exactly what time we're opening exactly
you came at 8 30 on the dollar still
like it's one place it's one [ __ ]
minute
that's fine
this is wild man
yeah he's going to meet her daughter
she's four years old
and
they're blaming the staff for getting
all the first interaction
with you
yo they're turning up over ice cream
right now
this is the angriest i've ever seen
known over ice
you can leave sir we can really call the
cops you're going to threaten a kid
you're going to get fired you're not
going anywhere you're going to get fired
that's fine what is your names
okay
so there's people defending each side of
this now my snap call here is that i
really don't feel like defending either
of them but obviously we have to pick
one now either one of these people if
they could have just been a little
reasonable could have resolved this
right
like you think if someone walks in right
up it's just ice cream too like if it's
a kitchen i get it you gotta go you
gotta cook it takes a long time this is
ice cream
okay it doesn't take that long for them
to prepare it i used to work at an ice
cream parlor for years okay and there is
a lot of cleanup that's why they always
say the mcflurry machine is down at
mcdonald's there is a lot of cleanup
with ice cream so do you think they had
started cleaning already
yeah i think they did start um i'm not
saying they should have but yeah i also
want to point out that the video the
time says 8 42 so that means they've
been in there arguing for about 12
minutes
possibly also but go ahead zach this is
a cold stone this is not just any ice
cream place that's a big deal there's a
lot of work that goes in the ice cream
creation right right that's very true
you add the toppings manually yeah but
but clearly in my opinion
the one that's wrong is the customer
i mean just go to another [ __ ] ice
cream store like and also
you know
[Music]
just go to a different ice cream store
bro you know
um
you got to have a little sympathy for
these these these are not owners of the
store they just want to go home they're
making minimum wage
serving people like you all day
i'm sorry bro it's just and then like
turning up like that and threatening
them getting their face like
just go to a different ice cream store
man
so in my opinion the customer is clearly
wrong
although the employees could have you
know
made the ice cream really easily and
resolved it so they're both being a
little bit
ridiculous the customer is being more
ridiculous thoughts i think it's however
you look at the argument like
i i feel like if you had
worked in a restaurant your life you'd
have more decency and be more
understanding of the staff
knowing that
it is a pain to you know last minute to
bring everything back up and then
they're not gonna get home for another
half hour
so i gotta side with the staff because
i've been there before as a waiter i
know it's a nightmare you know there is
the other wrinkle though it's like his
girl's birthday like have a heart just
make the ice cream what did it take for
a minute you know what i mean but still
i think he's wrong anyone else we
i i'm i'm gonna side with
the ice cream please there you have it
but me too um i'm curious to see how
when they walked in what happened yeah
could we have part one this is part two
yeah when i went to the original account
i could not find part one we need a part
one guys this is what's going around
everywhere hold on don't vote yet we
don't even have the wrong take that down
dan okay we don't have all the details
yet this is this is a bad pull
this is a bad bullet dan we need to
watch part one first okay
dan getting ahead of himself you said in
my opinion
in my opinion there is nothing that
justifies that kind of stuff exactly
that's a swede too like if you did that
in sweden you
you get a strong weird you get a
strongly worded letter
sent to your parents it's it's not wait
no one should act like this like
completely right right but i'm curious
who came at who first that's we need
part one desperately
we can't vote till we get it guys also
i mean
listen i worked in a restaurant as a
waiter for like six years
uh customers coming in last minute right
before you close is it's a [ __ ] worst
thing that can and it's known it's known
and it's known that it's a [ __ ]
terrible thing so angry that said
when people came in a minute before
close
i put on a smile and i serve still got
to accommodate it that's also true so
and to me it all
i can't make a decision about this i
need the security footage i need to know
if they really came in a minute before
clothes or not we need it if they did
you gotta give the guy the ice cream and
especially he's like yo i made it it's
my kid's birthday you got one minute but
if he's if it's 8 30. the problem is 30
in zero seconds get the [ __ ] out of the
store get the [ __ ] out
but i know you dan if someone's like yo
i'm sorry it's my daughter's birthday
she just wants ice cream you'd better
get yeah of course you would i think it
depends on the type of person that was
making the ice cream i understand you
know it's a hard day cold stone it's
[ __ ] messy [ __ ]
but you know they could have been having
a bad day
it's a tough one i gotta say it's it's
not that simple is it yeah well how
aggressive did he come at them you know
that's what we need yeah if he's like
right out of the gate screaming we need
that part
part one is where all the truth lies
someone's trying to bury part one
the truth is being hidden from us
yeah you're right man it's like
if you made it
you gotta make that ice cream nothing
justifies getting this thing any any
normal person would be like okay cool
damn that sucks bye or be like yo it's
my daughter's birthday please we gotta
see that part one look i need that cold
stone is worth the aggression because
really you'd fight over called birthday
cake remix man if that's what they were
getting goldstone
that's what i always did too yeah
birthday cake that's a great example
that i know that's why you brought it up
because that birthday cake remix there's
a big mess that goes into it because
they gotta like smear the brown exactly
so you think they were gonna order one
of those crazy ass ice creams it's
[ __ ] worth it though i'd i'd fight to
the death for it okay
zach is saying
worth fighting to the death over but
still i i think i still have to side
with the uh
the people that are working on ice cream
yeah i mean
from the point that we come into the
video the customer is clearly out of
control he's in their face i mean people
don't get paid enough to do that it's 12
minutes after closing at this point from
the beginning
this is not a good look obviously
that video
the employee seems like it's right but i
i got if they were there before they
were there before he says 7 29. and if
and we got to see the escalation because
maybe he didn't start you know he's at a
10 when we come into this how could we
not find part one but maybe he's at a
one at first and he's being reasonable
i'm sorry i don't know i i just i need
more information if
i i'd like to see the time code
like if it's 829 right and the only
evidence that we've found guys yeah
where's part one
they they said it was just a black
screen and them screaming the same thing
the original poster of the video is
private
i think they're hiding
they are hiding yeah what olivia said
isn't even the original post it's
someone responding to a re-upload yeah
the original guy is
this is changing my opinion
somebody pointed out too and i did catch
this as well and i wasn't
maybe you guys understood this more but
was he explaining that there was a line
to get into this yes that was also very
interesting well hold on let's watch
this again because if they make you wait
in line and be like yo it's closed
that's a problem yeah now let's listen
carefully here
ice cream listen i came out to finish
we told you
that's a problem
if they told them to wait in line and
then they don't serve them that's [ __ ]
up yeah i agree this is this is turning
this may not be i don't think the
customer doesn't drive fall i don't
think it's cut and dry now yeah again
it didn't have to escalate to that level
yeah the passion in it is is over but
just imagine though put yourself in his
shoes where it's like it's your
daughter's birthday they make you wait
in line and then you get in there like
we can't serve you yeah but then you
start arguing with them and they're like
yeah it's like it's like you know
obviously he's turning up too much but
it's really [ __ ] up yeah i'd be mad
too and i'd probably be like yo that's
[ __ ] and then leave i wouldn't go to
mcdonald's yeah just start screaming
pretend yeah so
but the machine's down
right yeah that's what i was saying
depends on what angle you're going at it
because there was guys who would come
into the restaurant i worked at and
would stay there three hours past close
when i'd have exam in the morning it'd
just be a [ __ ] nightmare there's
nothing i could do about it also i'd
like to see this ice cream though easy
compared to that the time code is it 8
29 in 15 seconds
or is it 8 29 and 45 seconds because
that's a big difference too
down to the second their closing time is
8 30. if it's if it's 2 29 and 59
seconds they walked in okay maybe that's
a little extreme but all right we're
splitting here we don't have that
information gotta give him the ice cream
right right here let's see with this and
his response was
i'm sorry i just wanted a frosty
and his that's his uh
apology right on the nose actually
so let's continue here because i'm
actually
my allegiance is actually moving to the
customer at this point i hate to admit
hold on this is important
we can't let customers
they were in line they she just
confirmed it right they were in the
store waiting in line and yeah the
employee is saying they were waiting
outside because of kovid
it sounds like the line was outside
we waited out line we were waiting and
then the employee says well we were busy
which means that they were tending to
the people in front of them she said we
can't lock you guys inside we can't lock
customers in yo
the employees are wrong
what there was a line and they were in
just because
we need more info they were in line and
then they told them to leave okay that's
insane we serve everyone in line just
because there's a line how many people
are there it's cold stone it's not like
a [ __ ] are you guys pretending like
it's uh they're right they're right to
get ice cream bro it's a private
business they can close whenever they
want you know
no i agree
if they say if they said
if they said hey we're closed sorry
we're not serving you ice cream the
customer is well within the right to be
annoyed and even
a little pissed
but
you're right love like if they're saying
we're not going to serve you just just
leave i mean it doesn't need to be a
confrontation yeah the outrage is yeah
it's my darn garn goddess no no no no no
i think i'm on their side
no obviously he turned up too fast and
too hard yeah but if i was waiting in
line
and it was my son's birthday and i was
getting his favorite ice cream and then
they're like yo you gotta leave i've
been waiting live for a few minutes now
or even longer i don't know how long
there that's [ __ ] up bro and i'm
throwing hands
also like i feel again i feel like it is
on the customer look they know the risk
going in when the cold stone is gone no
you in the store you get to buy well no
i'm just saying i feel like i feel like
you need to prep it's your kid's
birthday well sure why
why are you going like right when they
close and there's a risk of look i don't
know what happened in their day leading
up to this they're they're both wrong
but again nothing justifies the guy
telling the staff i i want you i want
you like
also you gotta you gotta follow the
golden rule never [ __ ] with people that
make food for you
just saying that says exactly what's on
the opening day
how many people are clamoring for ice
cream here we let you in with it there's
just a massive line of people begging
for there's a customer walking out of
the store so that's that's that's what
i'm saying they literally just are
finished making someone's order yeah
they're still
unlocked they just finished making
someone's order let me add another only
two other people in the shop there's
there's another mystery store and didn't
get the yogurt there's a there's the two
demi lovato knows quite well not getting
the ice and then i had a hard time the
rest of the weekend [ __ ] your whole week
hold on there's a dude in the background
yeah he's just casually eating ice cream
and pacing back and forth that's what
i'm saying who is he and what does he
have to this is like the third shoot or
the second shooter
right
here this is when you can get the best
look at him
you can kind of see yeah he just it
looks like he just got his order
and he leaves
the trunk he looks like a satisfied
customer yeah that means they just made
this dude's order just did it and they
said no [ __ ] you guys you got to leave
well no the time is 8 42 so this guy's
been here for 12 minutes
wait how do we know it's 8 40 look at
the look at the screen uh the cold stone
screen if you the pos system oh for real
you can see the time yeah also also the
the customer is filming so i'd like to
see that footage too well i want more
footage obviously we need part one we
need his footage
but so again we like we all agree that
he's turning up way too much it's insane
where do you see the time
go keep going
okay oh yeah 842 loud and clear
they've been arguing for 12 minutes
probably she just made the ice cream or
or maybe maybe they were waiting in line
also possible since the other dude 40
there
was their turn right now this video was
obviously posted by the employee
and they have intentionally left out
part one
uh
well apparent well maybe i don't know
part one was posted originally i think
where is it well apparently they set
their account to private and the reason
that they did that
is i gotta say
if you work
for a corporate chain restaurant like
that and you get into an argument with
the customer don't post it on the
internet
these employees are almost certainly
fired at this point whether or not they
were right i'm not making a judgment
call on whether or not they were right
but
don't self-report why would you post
that on the internet the cloud is not
worth it if you're arguing with a
customer like that
do not do not post your self-argument
yeah so again here here's the dude in
the background enjoying his eyes
i'm very curious if one of us tries this
tonight and i'm almost tempted to go to
a cold stone at 8 29 tonight i love this
shot the raging bicep dude he's the guy
behind him just casually eating ice
cream looking over
like damn i'm glad i got mine this ice
cream is supposed to be a happy time
this is war my friend yeah i think
you're supposed to be happy listen
listen i think it's time we take a vote
and with acknowledging that we're
missing the beginning of this
confrontation
and i think look
knowing that he turned up too hard
okay for sure
i'm gonna i'm gonna vote now go ahead
dan bring up the poll and make sure it's
good
how would you like me to word it ethan
who was who was uh more wrong
that's confusing
who was wrong
the customer who was wrong
the customer the worker the worker
don't do both i don't care about one or
the other you have a bad decision you
got it you got it who was wrong
this might shock you guys
my wife went out for yogurt without me
and then i had a hard time the rest of
the weekend guys i know this is i know
this is hard
and i at first i was like the cut i
gotta go with the the workers are right
but knowing they were waiting in line
unconfirmed no it was she confirmed it i
guess yeah but we don't know the extent
of the line we don't necessarily know
like if that's a loosely defined i'm
saying customer i'm sorry guys oh wait
no i voted for the wrong wait wait
question if this is happening
if this is happening at 8 43 does that
mean that there were people in there
past 8 30 still making ice he probably
ordered and was waiting for his order
right the order was already in so this
and they were just waiting for pick up
so this is 13 minutes after they're
closing
yeah at 8 43. i got to say 42. 40 this
oh wait do you guys think he made his
order no definitely not no but i'm
saying why are they arguing
are they arguing for 12 minutes this is
i think what i think happened is they
were waiting in line
and at 8 40
they're like or 7 40 or whatever they're
like yo we're closing we can't make your
order so they were waiting for 10
minutes in the store or right outside
the store yeah
they came into the line at 29 right or
that's what they say one minute
this poll is
you know we're at 60 40.
it's not cut and dry now you guys it's
easy to say
the customer is wrong
but if you ignore how over the top angry
he got which obviously is it's a factor
worth considering yeah if you ignore
that aspect i feel like the workers are
in the wrong here
which i'm doing i'm ignoring that he
like threatened me i genuinely feel like
there is no way to make a fundamental
call about this without we need part one
i need that security camera footage i
don't even need part one i need to see
the time stamp on the cctv
when did they enter the store if it was
before 8 30
they got an argument
now did they take it too far yes
absolutely you shouldn't yell at
employees like that it's just ice cream
move on with your [ __ ] life like it's
way over the top
if we're if we're just talking about the
origin of the conflict here
did they walk in before closing or not
without that information that's it
that's all that matters that to me
that's that's where
the divergence happens you gotta know
well okay so let's
let's try to build up another secret
what if you go into like a grocery store
and you get in there one minute before
it closes do you have the right to just
go around for to shop for like 10
minutes i mean i think it's because you
got in there before closing no actually
no and of course you start to
it's different love getting ice cream
only takes like a minute or two shopping
takes like an hour grocery stores will
usually close one of the doors walking
in there exactly that's a good point
zach they'll usually sweden
there's one door to enter and one to
exit bro
how about that well
right that's good
yeah
well in america
or like one one door i mean another one
for each yeah
that's true a lot of times they'll let
you a lot of stores do this where
they'll close the entrance at the
closing time
and everyone in the store can finish
shopping i bet you didn't know that to
finish usually they they say like you
gotta better hurry up
in america
well i don't know exactly but surely
they can't just let people walk around
there for 30 minutes well they'll be
like shoppers were yeah you know they'll
put something on the intercom yeah they
turned the lights off i mean lena once
at target
did they yeah
so who was wrong and who was right in
that situation
get your [ __ ] ass up i guess we were
wrong
when the lights went off huh were you
pissed when the lights went off i'm like
well this is trippy i've never been in a
store with the lights off they almost
they almost trapped your ass in there
like uh the kid in the mall after
closing oh yeah i had to sleep on some
stuffed animals
um okay well there you have it you know
yep
ultimately we don't have enough
information i think you're right dan
there's one thing for sure that's gonna
come out of all this what's that game
i'm gonna get some cold stone after work
today oh yeah that sounds good that does
sound and i'm going at 8 29 8 29 what
happened yeah no i'm going to go before
i don't even want to get i don't want
that heat
but i do want
birthday birthday cake yeah remix it
used to i mean it would drive me insane
when people would come in right before
closing at a restaurant and i would
never do that myself and i would never
uh you know find myself in the scenario
that
this uh customer did in this video
dan when you're working at that
restaurant i'm not gonna name it if
someone let's say you closed at nine and
someone walked in it i don't know yeah
don't dox the rest 8 45
would you still serve them yeah that's
what i'm saying the kitchen wouldn't be
closed no okay we would all be annoyed
and probably curse them out in the back
but no i mean you gotta
and you know why
because if i told somebody
hey
sorry we're closed and we're not
actually closed and they get mad and
call corporate i'm getting fired which
again is why i think it was a horrible
call for these people to post they
should be getting bonuses because all
you guys are getting the cold stones now
we're selling ice good marketing it's
viral marketing i mean those those those
workers should be getting raises
that's why i'm saying
regardless of who
is in the right or not terrible idea to
post that don't post yourself getting
into an altercation at work you are
asking to get fired even if you're in
the right just because companies they
don't give a [ __ ] about you and they'll
fire you for anything
this really turned into a heated
discussion actually
very happy birthday to his daughter
she's crying right now she didn't get
the ice cream she wanted now her whole
wig's ruined
um how long we've been going dan
we have been going for almost three
hours and we do have to wrap it up hold
on we got kevin spacey we have are they
really that loud yeah it's going to be
very loud [ __ ] yeah and we've been going
i mean we got three i think they need
our help too did we get into that
what else we got in the title we didn't
talk about anything in the title
we had the great debate we had the great
debate we had the great debate didn't
talk about brittany or kevin spacey
so here let me tell you real fast kevin
spacey has been charged in relation to
allegations he got kevin spacey got
arrested
bada-bing
and um britney spears her ex-boyfriend
crashed her wedding and wow it was
really scary okay
we'll probably
but guys thanks for watching
wednesday we will be back
it is wednesday
oh yeah we need to wrap it up i need to
move my car when i need you guys
so we'll be back on wednesday for off
the rails
regular sketch thank you all everyone
who has become a member thank you for
the gifted subs so cool so nice
appreciate you all guys
act man people are talking about asking
about the act man he's going to be
calling in on wednesday actually
so there you go to discuss
that you might have missed it when you
were at the bathroom but i got to give a
shout out to p and oreo together they've
gifted probably around 600 uh members
uh the shells during the chelsea
manning's show so big shout out to p and
oreo shout out thank you oh yeah
that's just two separate people or two
separate people yeah okay he donated
more than oreo i got not gonna lie but
oreo is the legend too wow p
p and oreo thank you guys that's very
nice
appreciate that
and uh
all right
thank you guys
we'll see you next time i hope you guys
enjoyed
was a fun app it was really nice with
martin martin was great
yeah super great
all right
have a good uh evening guys see you
later bye
[Music]
you